如果你不常用它，它从你的记忆里消失了，那这个东西就完完全全浪费在你的仪柜里，闲置了。
Mouse如果能带到头上，起到功能的同时轻弱无误，简直就是太厉害了。
Mouse
Hello 大家好，这里是月下户外频道，我是老柴。这期我们要来讲讲装备。
装备一直是我们频道特别受欢迎的一个板块。
然后这两年因为我做月下，越来越多的朋友经常会请教我一些装备的问题。
我也谈不上请教，就是因为可能跟很多嘉宾录的比较多，所以有一些见闻。
然后我发现大家有个需求，就是很多新入坑户外的或者某一项运动的朋友总是希望说我能不能在买装备的时候能符合一些原则。
譬如说有人希望性价比高，有人希望能一步到位，有人有具体的场景需求。
所以这一期我们来聊一聊我们在日常的这个装备选择当中的一些建议。
所以本期我又邀请了我的好伙伴切尔哥跟大家一起来聊一聊关于装备的选择。
为什么邀请切尔哥呢？
切尔哥是前面介绍过他是一个在户外当中已经有多少年历史。
哈喽大家好，还没有跟大家打招呼。
我进入户外圈其实是从06年就开始接触了，然后深度的开始，那时候就是接触过一两次攀岩，
然后深度的开始玩攀岩就是每天都爬是从08年，所以其实是已经有将近20年的时间了。
所以在20年里面，切尔哥你有印象你买过多少件户外的装备吗？
那简直是数不上数，因为我是一个超级的装备党，我对装备是有一种就是吃米的状态，
就像很多女孩可能喜欢买包，我真的是装备能给我带来无尽的愉悦。
对，上次我去切尔哥家做课，因为我们俩有一期想要尝试一下直播，
后来我发现切尔哥的卧室几乎是被所有的户外装备围绕的，
但是是多而不乱，他甚至有一个专门的装备墙，如果大家感兴趣的话，我们会在note里面给大家展示。
所以我想请切尔哥来我们俩聊这一期，可能从我这个行业的角度，
切尔哥从他用户的角度，我们都可以跟大家聊聊这个装备推荐的一些，我们自己的一些见解吧。
但是在这首先声明啊，就是因为我们俩肯定不算全面，都是个人使用者，
因此呢，也许不那么客观，也不那么全，我们只是轻松的聊一聊说我们选的一些装备。
那在这期开始之前呢，我们还想了一个我俩选择装备的一个原则，叫做长期主义。
那首先我问问切尔哥，你怎么定义长期主义这四个字，先不说装备吧，什么叫长期主义呢？
就是其实我个人生活习惯有一个原则，就是物尽其用，就是一个东西，就是你买了它，或者你拥有了它，你要不断地使用它，它才有它存在的意义。
否则我觉得就是极大的浪费。
对，我觉得这是长期主义的一个点，然后因为好多朋友问我说，有没有什么性价比比较高的东西？
这些性价比也许是长期主义的一个点，因为只有性价比高了，咱们的钱才花得比较物有所值，然后我们可能也能得到更大的支持。
然后除了这个呢，我觉得一物多用也是我的一个考量的原则，就是当它有更多的使用场景的时候，它的利用率就会高，
就是你能记起使用这个产品，或者说这一件服装的这个机会也多一些。
因为其实现在我觉得大家就是物质极大丰富，我真的是我每年比如一换季打开我的衣柜，我都会想起，哦，我觉得还有一个这样的衣服，哦，还有，就像真的是像我工商厂一样，完全没有记忆的一个全新的产品摆在我面前。
所以我觉得就是如果你不常用它，它从你的记忆里消失了，那这个东西就是完完全全浪费在你的衣柜里，显至了。
嗯，的确，尤其是在寸土寸京的一些城市，譬如说我们现在所在的北京，如果一个东西它不能一物多用，或者不能高频使用的话，
它站着也许它站的那个面积都远高于，我们就不说那个售价了，就从租金的角度来看，可能也远高于这个产品的价值。
所以我觉得这也是，然后另外就还有一个是大家提到长期主义最容易提及的一个点就是环保。
因为环保这两年好像是一阵全球性的风潮，但我觉得除了风潮之外，我们每个人确实，切切实实的还是希望去保护我们所在的这个地球，然后所去探索的这些户外环境。
所以就是环保这个也是促使我今天特别想要跟大家聊聊这一期的原因。
我先讲一个小故事吧，因为我们一直在做一些户外行业的调研和项目的一些运营。
然后在这个过程里面，我们就发现在网络上找数据的时候，发现中国最近有一个被归纳在户外板块下的内幕的电商增长非常非常的快。
是什么呢？就是大家出行的洗漱用品，包括洗漱包，毛巾，然后还有隔脏税店，还有一些类似的东西。
但是令人心痛的是，我们在拿到的某平台的数据上，top 10的里面有九个全都是一次性的。
其实大家可能也越来越多的看到这两年有很多的人走进了山里。
这是一个好事啊，就是大家全民这个户外热潮给人们都带来了开心和健康。
但是我们经常在到处看到白色的垃圾，这些垃圾以前可能是塑料袋取得。
现在你动不动就会看到一些没有办法降解的一些一次性毛巾之类的。
所以就是我们今天聊聊可能环保这个角度也是想聊的。
所以一步到位的一物多用的高性价比的环保的，这是我和切尔哥目前我们对于长期主义的大概的一个定义。
再强调一次就这次节目不是特别的严谨或者说全面，我们就是一个个人角度的一个描述，
也希望启发大家的同时如果各位有好的这个产品推荐的话，也欢迎在评论区还有我们的热闹的群里面能分享出来给大家。
好，那第二个部分呢，我想问问切尔哥，就是你最近观察到的趋势就是大家在采买这些装备的时候，你或者身边的人有一些什么样的变化吗？
变化，我觉得只能说是我身边的人可能就是关注坏运动，极限运动人越来越多了。
然后以前大家可能就跟风嘛，就是无脑跟风，就是看什么买得多或者是品牌曝光率高，他就会去考虑直接就购买了。
然后现在一个我觉得可能大的经济形式也不太好，然后大家购买这些相对专业的用品的时候，他们会更慎重，然后他们会更多的去问身边的这些就是从业者或者说是就是玩这个运动相对专业一点的有经验的自身的一些人群，然后去了解。
先去做一些功课吧，然后做完功课之后去对自己的需求相对有针对性的去做决策去购买。
我觉得这个是一个我能看到的趋势。
对，我也特别感同身受就一个是参与的人越来越多了，所以我显得突然更有价值。
就是以前因为我从一二年对开始进入坏行业，以前我感觉我在朋友圈里面就是自己的专业并没有那么吃香，然后现在就很吃香，就经常有人问说，老柴你有推荐的地方吗？
我要学一个运动你有推荐的教练吗？社团吗？
然后当然说到这如果大家有这方面需求首先先进群啊，进群的方式在我们的那个note里面都有。
然后另外就是大家会问我更多的是说，你给我推荐一个什么样的装备，说实话我觉得我也不算专业，因为我们看的更多的是宏观的内容比较多，
但是而如木染的身边经常会有些嘉宾啊大神啊爱好者啊推荐的一些产品，所以我这是我的一个很大的感受就是人群变多了。
第二个就是像切尔哥刚刚提到的，我觉得人们的理性决策的这个比重在上升，就以前确实有一大轮的这种户外热潮，我之前讲过就是我身边，
以前只买LV的一个妹子突然拉着我去逛十足鸟，我就感觉到大事不妙。
我身边也有一个这样的人，说他突然跟我说，我发现十足鸟的充分音还挺好看的，是一个超级物质的金钟女。
但是这个说大事不妙其实带引号的，我们还是高兴的，因为我们乐见其成说整个户外行业在起来，然后人们无论你是因为对衣服的喜欢走进了户外，还是因为对户外的喜欢爱上了衣服，
我觉得对我们行业都是有促进的，这对个人的健康也是很好的。
然后只是说在前面那一阵风潮里面，大家好像更多的是的确把它当做一个潮流，我们不是说潮流不好，这也很好，就是当做一个潮流。
但这两年呢，就是因为很多人都在讲说消费降级或者说理性消费，越来越多的人在研究说这个衣服它好在哪里不好在哪里，性价比高在哪买更合算，我觉得这也是一个趋势。
然后我自己看到的第三个趋势就是我们前面讲的，的确还是有较多的人开始关注了环保，虽然我自己的感受就是在我身边可能爱好者的环保意识还是有很大的提升的空间，包括我自己也是。
只是说这个趋势我觉得还是像好的，然后大家也会在想说有哪些东西我们不是一次性去使用的，然后有哪些东西我们可能比如说我们穿过的衣服如何进行二次利用，或者说包括我们看到有很多品牌在做破损的，比如说冲锋衣裤的一些修理，我觉得这些也都是一个趋势吧。
然后还有就是品牌的多样性也越来越明显了，以前可能就那老几家，但是现在因为中国品牌崛起了也很多，比如说我们自己月下也是一个新生的一个女性户外品牌，也包括说像国外的品牌进来的也非常多这两年，所以就是人们好像也在品牌选择上会更去中心化，大概我觉得趋势可能就这些。
那接下来要不我们就直接进入到很干很干的环节，我们从衣服、鞋子、背包、配件、然后睡眠系统和其他的一些小物以及电子产品这几个板块来分别聊聊咱俩的一些感受吧，好不好，乔哥。
好的，那我们先从衣服聊起吧，这可能是大家最关注的，就是户外衣服可能都会有哪些类目以及你平常都怎么选。
户外衣服我觉得我可能会更注重场景性的，就是因为我会玩一些户外的项目，比如我经常去攀岩，然后有时候去瑜伽，有时候徒步，有时候露营，然后还有滑雪，潜水等等，就是所有的这种专业的类目，其实它对服装都是会有一定的要求和限制，
所以我可能会从这些角度去考虑，我可能是从点，我现在说的可能是一些局部的点，这些点就是它某一个运动属性非常强的，然后它可能会有一些点性的要求，然后还有就是到面，
就比如说我可能因为其实这是我的一个户外的生活方式了，所以我可能就会更考虑我产品的一个就是能覆盖的更多场景的可能性。
比如说我攀岩，而且现在其实你去养馆，你看姑娘们穿的全是瑜伽服，就是露背的，然后露腰的，其实这也不是什么坏事，就是它攀岩以前可能是更苦的一个运动，
但是现在它社交属性变强了，姑娘们觉得当社交属性强了之后，美美的去从事一项运动，并且还能留下美美的照片或者视频，他们其实更乐于从事其中，
而且这个项目会给它带来更多的愉悦感，我觉得这些都是对人变美，变健康，变美好的一个很好的趋势，
所以我觉得瑜伽服可能是女性从事运动的一个最通用性的服装，然后裤子的话我觉得可能它会对专业要求会高一些，
比如说攀岩你要耐磨，瑜伽的话你要更好的拉伸，然后徒步的话其实也是，比如说你要考虑到场景防蚊虫，然后防擦伤，还有就是它的素杆和透气，
那我觉得可能一方面特别专的这种功能的趋势之后再往大面上走，那我可能考虑的就是面料的需求，
比如说我裤子我更多的就是选保软盒或者素杆，它的使用场景更多一些，然后硬壳裤其实说实话在日常的使用场景下没有那么多，
可能更多的我只有滑雪的时候才会用到，然后就是到保暖层，保暖层就是我们现在就比较流行的趋势就是羊毛，
羊毛因为它的异军和防臭确实是我使用下来之后非常受用的一点，就是因为我经常运动，
所以我可能我就变成了一个异汗体制，就是我平时就是稍微动一下我就会出汗，然后我就会觉得我能闻到我身上的汗味，
但是如果我穿的是一件羊毛内衣的话，或者说羊毛的这种就是短袖，因为我们现在也有很多这种，
包括月下也有了就是羊毛的这种T恤，我夏天我也完全可以穿羊毛，然后我就不用那么担心，因为其实我是能闻见我身上有汗味的，
但是我的衣服上是没有汗味的，所以我不用，比如说我身边离我很近的站了一个人，我不用太担心这个人能闻到我身上的汗味，
然后再往外说那就是后一点的中层，比如说就是保暖层，比如就是软壳，软壳或者是超轻的这种皮绵的绵符和羽绒符，
然后这个其实就是一个可以穿在冲锋衣里面的一个保暖层，其实它替代的就是我们常规理解的毛衣的这一层功能，
然后再往外就是硬壳或者是防水的冲锋衣，或者是防泼水的这种外套，然后再往外就是比较厚的那种类似，
就是比如说我们去一个露营场景，然后晚上过夜的时候会非常冷，
所以我们可能会在冲锋衣外面再搭一个更厚的保暖的羽绒符，就是最后的羽绒符，大概是这样的一个穿衣逻辑。
我觉得切尔哥已经说得非常全面了，为了让大家更好的这个有场景化，
那我们一个一个来扒，然后顺便带出一些他推荐的产品和品牌来，我们先说最简单的这个攀岩和瑜伽，先说瑜伽吧，你有特别喜欢的装备吗？
瑜伽其实我觉得，就是我基本上考虑的就是好看，我觉得因为瑜伽毕竟它是一个很轻的一个运动，
而且它基本上是一个短的场景，就是你不可能说去搞它一天，或者是到一个很极限的环境去搞，
所以我觉得就是不用太考虑面料的科技性，可能考虑的还是它的穿着的一个是舒适的体感，
还有一个就是美观，就是它得合体，就是因为瑜伽服大多数人理解，它就是相对暴露，
它会，我说的暴露不光是露幅度，它还有就是它能体现你线条的这种暴露，
就基本上很多人就说这姑娘穿了一身瑜伽服，没露肉，但是感觉她什么都没穿，
就是它会非常体现你的这种身体线条，所以我觉得就是一定要一个就是它可能有一些产品，
它从结构上，结构设计上它能修饰你的那个体型，还有一种就是它可能不把你的缺陷暴露出来，
我觉得可能更多的是考虑这一点。
所以品牌方面你有推荐吗？
品牌可能我更多的用的就是lululemon。
我也是lulu的死忠用户，然后lulu的产品里面其实我个人感受也不是说每一款都百分之百好，
我自己特别喜欢的就是裤子就是align，我觉得经营好像是align推出的十周年，
我们还去公体参加了它那个活动，但是我觉得align当之无愧，
因为刚开始它火的时候很多人说有很多替代的产品就是相对比较便宜或者说是一些国产版，
就是他们家其他产品我都试过的确是有国产替代，
但是align的料子，据说这只是一个江湖传言，说是他们的这个面料的保密程度其实是跟设置品一样，
如果这个面料在做完这批裤子之后没有使用完他们就会销毁，
所以就是align的裤形作为一个我是一个体质率有34%的人，确实不怎么好看，
但是只有这个裤子穿上之后它的松紧程度刚好，然后弹性刚好。
在这里面还有个小tips，虽然可能听众里面不多，
但是假设说你最近有怀孕打算的话，align是孕妇穿着特别友好的一条裤子，
因为它在腐布的这个收缩性，我之前穿一条8号的，然后我自己的身高是1米59，
然后我怀孕的时候一度达到了130，8号是完全没有问题的，你不会有任何的压迫感。
所以就是这是我推荐的一款，然后另外一个就是上一的那个define，
它那个外套有那个结构分线设计的那款也是非常非常显瘦和舒服的，
然后我自己在lulu方面就推荐这两件，然后除此之外呢，
因为我觉得lulu的价格还是相对比较坚挺的，
如果大家寻求一些新价比比较好的品牌，
包括这两年大家很多人被称为叫他们也不叫运动时尚叫什么运动潮流的这个内幕里面，
比如说alow它这两年很火，我觉得就身材很好的女孩子，
alow的定价可能会比lulu还要高一些，对对对对，
就是如果是追求潮流的女孩子可以去考虑这些品牌，
然后国内比如说像myactive啊这些品牌也都口碑不错，
然后如果要性价比更高，哦对我前面忘介绍了，
就是我们今天这些节目我们希望是价格是高中低档都能够覆盖，
这样的话会更有意义些，如果是要性价比非常高的话，
我非常非常推荐大家去看一下1688，
对就是以前我也不懂1688的这个逻辑啊，
我以为它和拼多多类似，后来发现不是1688的确更多的是工厂货源，
就是源头啊，对对对，源头工厂，
所以它价格有可能跟拼多多差不多，
但是我自己的感受是1688上的产品你买到相对质量好一点的机率要比拼多多更高，
只是它的购物体验没有那么好，
因为它那个界面设计的是说你拿货的，
但是其实你只要一件可以拿的，就那个价格就可以拿，
所以就是如果是1688的话类似的产品外型差不多，
可能体验会差一些，
但是我觉得性价比还是极高的，
就可以能到大概几十块也许三四十块就能买到可以穿的一些衣服，
我觉得是这个也推荐给大家。
我是有体会的，就是因为我的鱼家库就是我鱼家库特别肥，
因为我偶尔可能有时候会去攀岩，
所以我当时在淘宝上就是纯买的这种，
它可能确实是copy的这种陆陆类型的这种鱼家库的基础款，
然后我的体验也很好，
当时那个价格可能是100来块钱，
它也有很多颜色，
我就不一样的颜色买了好几条，
我就觉得这种可能它试措成本没有那么高，
然后它可能面料确实没有，
就是陆陆那么柔软，
但是我觉得穿着体验也很好了，
就是因为它可能裁减啊什么的，
它已经学习了很多大牌的这种经验，
然后我运动背心其实是我一直，
我是属于那种就是运动型身材，
就我再加上我也是特别喜欢，
就是我从审美的角度，
我也更喜欢这种把肩膀露出来的这种穿衣风格，
所以我可能从很小的时候，
我就特别喜欢在运动的时候穿的是背心这样的一个品类，
所以我一直在关注各种品牌的背心，
直到陆陆出现了之后，
我才发现原来运动背心可以这么美，
然后因为陆陆的出现，
导致其实会有更多的运动品牌去优化他们的产品设计，
所以其实后来我还更关注到一个相对小众的品牌，
就是Adidas Estella的一个系列，
然后这个系列它就会有很多非常好的，
小众设计的这种女性的运动背心，
所以我觉得大家如果感兴趣的话，
也可以去关注一下，
但是这个可能国内比较少，
我都是海豹或者咸鱼去找，
Adidas和Nike这两个运动背心里边，
如果是纯技术款的话，
我更喜欢Nike的，
因为在最开始没有陆陆的时候，
我基本上都是买Nike的运动背心，
然后后来因为Adidas Estella的这个系列被我看到之后，
我发现它可能会更时尚和更偏重女性化，
而且它会和很多那种小众的艺术家去做联名，
所以我觉得那个品牌是让我关注到的一个，
从设计角度看比较喜欢的品牌，
说到运动背心，
因为很多人都买不到自己合适的，
这也是一个大的点，
然后我在这补充一下，
因为Cherga的身材属于非常非常fit，
然后她有每天高品的这种运动习惯，
所以我也观察到一个现象就是国内，
不就是现在市面上大多数的这个运动品牌，
其实设计的衣服大多数是为你们这样的人设计的，
就是本来很好看，
但大多数像我这样就是比较，
就身材非常普通，
然后也有一些短板的人，
尤其是我胸比较大，
然后就很难买到书记的，
我怎么觉得是自然发尔塞的，
这真的不是，
就是因为胖的，
因为我体脂率有34%，
所以我们其实买那个运动背心是有困难的，
但在这儿我跟大家说，
如果你是要从事一些非常需要减震的运动，
Nike的运动内衣是我穿过的减震最好的，
但是它另外一个不好的点就是，
因为它减震很好，
所以它很累的你很难受。
我是觉得穿脱非常艰难，
其实我可能是算偏瘦的，
然后我穿脱都很困难，
然后我表妹是一个，
可能比老柴还要肉活一点的姑娘，
她也很喜欢，
就是运动的时候穿那种简正性能好的背心，
然后她就一直困扰，
Nike的背心她穿不上也脱不下，
一个人无法独立完成这件事。
是的,
尤其是你出了汗之后，
这个就确实很困难，
所以当然我们这个体验也不全面，
也许人家出了比如说，
前拉链啊，
或者背扣式的这种可能会好一些。
但是其实说到前拉链，
就是我真的是不止一次的遇到过我身边的姑娘，
就是她的前拉链在，
就是运动的过程中开了，
那个真的是极端尴尬，
因为她的那个，
她本来就是强度很大嘛，
她才会设计拉链，
你好穿脱，
但是如果就是穿这样的衣服，
一定要反复的检查拉链，
拉上之后，
她会有向下按的那个动作去锁指这个拉链，
但是确实也避免不了在你运动的时候，
她会开，
她哪怕没有全开，
她开到一半，
其实,
因为肉是完全被勒住的嘛，
所以你开到一半，
她就会有一些肉挤出来，
就确实很尴尬。
我觉得这个是可能大家在日常穿的时候，
一定要小心的点。
然后推荐完这些价格比较高一些的，
如果是大家想尝试一些比较评价一些的，
我觉得抵卡农的运动内衣，
我穿过我觉得还行，
有一款是前开拉链的，
但它唯一的问题就是，
就是你穿上很贴身的衣服的时候，
拉链那个地方有一个包，
对对对，
这个是一个问题。
然后另外就是，
我还经常买的淘宝友家店，
叫Fit Show,。
就是大家可以去看一下，
它一件运动内衣大概就是60-80块钱，
反正你也不心疼，
但他们家有一些基础款，
就是一定不要买那些特别花哨的，
你按销量排名，
有一些基础款，
真的是很好，
是因为以前我有在跟一个工厂的大哥，
我去他们厂里学习的时候，
我才发现，
原来中国的这个运动内衣的产业链，
也非常非常的发达，
它应该是在帮Zara全球做运动线的东西，
然后他们也会帮一些品牌做运动内衣，
所以我提到，
当年Brufit Show这个品牌，
是有一个品牌叫暴走罗利，
对，然后就是也是在他们家生产的，
后来他给我看了生产线之后，
他说,
其实这个跟很多大牌的差异也不会太大，
所以如果大家追求设计，
追求品牌性能，
追求非常细节的美的话，
可以买大牌，
但如果说大家追求性价比的话，
我觉得这几个品牌，
也都可以看一看，
也欢迎大家在这个评论区补充，
就是好误大家共同来分享，
然后说完这个瑜伽的，
潘言我们刚提到说，
你会穿一些瑜伽类的衣服，
但是,
比如说潘言裤和潘言鞋，
你有什么推荐吗？
说到潘言，
就是我认识户外，
了解户外，
从事户外，
我就是从潘言这个内幕开始的，
所以呢，
就是我和现在，
很多这种，
就是刚出入户外圈子的，
同学们，
完全不是一样的路径，
所以我觉得，
可能大家了解户外的，
这个路径的，
方式,
可能也决定了，
你对你的户外装备，
和户外品牌的认知，
是有一定的影响吧，
就是我，
因为我先从潘言开始的，
然后,
我接触的最开始，
就是我身边的人，
大神们给我推荐，
适合的潘言鞋，
所以我就是，
呃,
质爱的，
就是,
潘言鞋的品牌，
然后,
因为,
对潘言的热爱，
然后,
导致我对这个品牌的，
终成度就非常的高，
然后,
直到这个品牌开始，
后来我发现，
它有徒步鞋，
有越野跑鞋，
也有服装，
然后,
所以我就会，
不管它好不好穿，
我先,
愿意,
就是去，
冒一定的风险，
去尝试它，
所以就是我，
对,
我会去试，
但是,
你要说到，
潘言铺，
其实,
这个品牌的服装，
它可能是欧版的，
而且它，
它在国内，
并没有大规模的去推广，
然后,
所以它没有特别适合，
中国的体型的产品，
所以,
潘言铺，
其实我试过他们家的，
其实到现在看，
并不是十分的理想，
然后,
但是是在我，
因为我之前，
经常逛那种，
要来那类的，
就是,
折扣店，
因为它会经常，
卖一些，
国外的，
小众的，
地面上也没那么发达，
所以那个时候，
我无意间发现了一个，
就是,
应该是人家亲货的，
一个品牌，
叫野玫瑰，
这个牌子当时，
就是,
我只能说分享一下，
我的户外对，
对产品了解的这个经历了，
它现在可能，
很难找到了，
但是，我现在衣柜里，
可能野玫瑰的裤子，
我有四、五条，
就是因为我当时穿了，
太好穿了，
然后,
我就,
只要是遇到，
比如这种，
这种亲户，
还有这个品牌的裤子，
所以就是有穿肺的。
然后到现在还能攒下这么多条。
当然我觉得就是后来凯勒什出的叛严裤。
就是他凯勒什已经非常的认真的去研究这个。
就是这个泪目下的他所有的检查还有面料。
所以我觉得他的设计已经非常用心了。
他有很多细节
板型是很重要的一点。
还有就是面料
就是野玫瑰的裤子。
其实我觉得他最核心的优势就是他的面料。
特别舒适
他是就是他的弹性像瑜伽裤一样。
但是他非常的薄
就是你知道他薄到你穿上。
他感觉没穿
就那么一个薄的素干。
而且他是一个素干裤。
那个面料就我很难形容。
就是现在很多就是思想弹力的这种素干面料。
很少有能像他做到那么薄和那么柔软的。
然后所以我可能到后来。
我可能关注就是攀岩裤的话。
我可能就是更喜欢。
第一就是他的弹性是不好。
然后他的面料是不是够轻薄。
然后因为他只要够轻薄。
他的透气性就会很好。
然后就是他的检查。
就是攀岩裤可能
一个是你的腰不能太累。
因为你上高腿的时候。
你肚子上的肉会拥挤到一起。
然后还有一个就是你的臀部。
他要够宽敞
就是因为Las Potipas的攀岩裤我穿了。
就是他不是很舒服。
就是他有点累当
就是亚洲人穿会有点累当。
然后还有就是他的裤脚。
他的裤脚是不是要有收口。
因为你攀岩裤就是你的那个。
你要低头能看到你的脚点什么的。
所以你的裤脚要有这种明显的收缩。
然后就是好看了
就是因为有的裤子他确实功能设计得很好。
然后穿上之后显得很优种。
或者说暴露你的体型缺陷。
那我觉得这个就依然而易。
可能大家要去试一下。
我目前看到市面上。
确实就是通用性
整个我综合我刚刚说的这几点。
比较好的确实是凯洛士的裤子。
就是大家的认可度也比较高。
嗯
攀岩因为相对比较小众。
但这两年也非常火嘛？
我觉得我们聊一聊他的那个衣服裤子。
大家就相对心里有数了。
那本来说鞋子是下一个板块聊。
但既然聊到这我们就把衣服鞋子。
按照这个运动内幕都说了吧？
攀岩鞋是一个很小众的内幕也很专业。
因为我第一次进盐馆的时候。
我才发现原来攀岩鞋跟别的鞋。
是有这么大的区别。
然后他有一个自己的体系。
你刚提到了拉斯普提法。
那除了拉斯普提法。
还有现在就是大家比较流行的品牌吗？
攀岩鞋其实也有很多的。
我们有一个兄弟品牌。
必须得给他做个很高就Batura。
因为Batura这两年。
其实他们在我这个兄弟的努力的推广下。
其实在全国的这种就是认知度和好感度。
其实都提升了很多。
而且Batura做了很多这种。
就是很好看的配色的这种设计。
所以我觉得对于这种初学体验。
想买自己低双攀岩鞋。
因为它价格性价比也比较高。
我觉得其实是可以关注这个品牌的。
然后还会有一些就是。
有的时候最早期我们接触攀岩。
会有Fepton这个品牌。
但是现在基本上它已经消失了。
当然那个品牌的鞋也是非常好穿的。
说到这也刚好跟大家说明一下。
就是我们本期节目提到的品牌。
如果跟我们有利益相关的。
我们一定会跟大家说清楚。
这样便于大家来决策。
Batura的确是我们的好朋友。
在中国一直在努力推广的一个品牌。
它本身是韩国品牌对吧？
对
所以它的专业度确实是非常无话可说。
就是很专业的一双鞋子。
然后并且现在在国内知名的严管里面。
大家基本上都能看到它的身影。
然后在这提到一个利益点。
就是如果大家想买Batura的鞋的话。
可以去某宝搜Batura。
就B-U-T-O-R-A品牌执营店。
然后跟客服说是老柴的朋友。
就可以获得八折
但这里面我们没有任何其他的商业利益。
就是他们没买一双鞋。
我们也不会有佣金之类的。
这个大家可以放心。
但是这个产品
因为的确是大家用过很专业的一个鞋子。
如果是你攀岩刚入门。
不知道选什么品牌的鞋的话。
我觉得你选它至少不会出错。
然后等到你入门之后。
你再根据你的喜好。
再可以选更多的鞋子。
记得老柴的朋友可以打八折。
说到这我就特别有面子。
然后在这刚好说一下。
就是我们在三个户外群里面。
都有长期置顶的福利会总。
然后如果是谈到一些品牌。
我都会放在里面
大家可以随时在群里面看。
好 那说完攀岩
我们来说说大家特别关注的第二个场合。
就是徒步或者登山。
那在徒步登山里面可说很多了。
除了我们刚刚说到。
因为切尔哥提到了。
比如说贴身层
我们会有一些像Lulu类似的衣服。
或者说你认为在登山徒步当中。
你一般都选什么牌子的衣服。
你可以从里到外跟大家讲讲。
我觉得就是如果是说大一点。
就是比如说我在做从事户外运动的时候。
我首先我肯定考虑的就是功能性服装。
这个是必然的
那它不光是徒步登山还滑雪。
其实这些都是在
就是你人在长时间要在自然。
而且可能会比较严克的这种自然条件下的这种穿着。
我可能会综合去考虑。
他们都是
因为我其实是一物多用的一个超级的奉行者。
所以我比如说我内层我可能考虑的就是。
它登山也能穿滑雪也能穿。
然后所以我觉得就是我们可以把滑雪也拉进来。
就是在说服装这一块的时候。
我想如果是从外层讲的话。
就是那其实就是冲锋衣。
就是硬壳衣裤
那这个能讲的品牌就太多了。
一个就是我们就是我肯定最近从事的火柴棍的这个推广工作会比较多。
所以我对火柴棍的这个感情很深。
再有一个就是我对它的产品有了更多的了解之后。
我就发现第一就是火柴棍。
它当它是一个北欧品牌。
然后瑞典品牌
所以它的设计是非常具备北欧特色的。
就是极简和高级感。
这是我的最大的感受。
所以其实我觉得冲锋衣在你考量它的面料的科技的同时。
我可能更多的就是因为冲锋衣的同志化非常多。
就是所有的带一点的牌子。
它可能比如3L的这种GoTex它全都有对吧？
那我可能更多的考量就是它的设计。
它的拼色的冲锋衣的设计是我最认可的一点。
很多滑雪服我觉得它如果就是在没有特别冷的时候。
穿冲锋衣冲锋裤就够了。
它其实就是一个单层。
然后可能会有一些专门的滑雪服。
它就会多加一些保温的夹层和雪裙的设计。
然后裤子可能也是。
就是可能它并不是一个刀皮儿。
它可能会加上一个防雪的一个脚套的那种设计。
但是本着一物多用的情况下。
我觉得可能第一就是我裤子的话。
防水裤我可能就是考虑买滑雪裤。
因为滑雪裤首先第一它裤脚够肥。
所以它能包住我的雪鞋。
但是如果我买了一个冲锋裤。
我就没有办法去滑雪。
因为它包不住我的雪鞋。
所以这个很重要
对 这从裤子上考量。
就是你可能买一个滑雪裤。
它的防水系数就一定够。
然后那你在真的在比如雨林徒步。
真的需要去穿一个纯防水的一个裤子的时候。
你可能可以坚固着考虑你穿你的滑雪裤就好了。
所以滑雪裤我觉得可能就买一个单层的滑雪裤。
你里边就是根据气候的要求去调整你的内层穿搭就好了。
然后上衣的话我觉得还是以好看为主。
然后雪裙这个功能就是。
其实我现在用到的不多。
就是可能初学经常摔跤的话。
雪裙是很有必要的。
再有一个就是如果你滑粉雪的话。
可能雪裙是有必要的。
因为很多其实硬壳裤的设计。
它就是一个背带裤。
就是它多多少少会高一些。
它的腰会高一些
所以如果你是一个相对高腰的背带裤的这种设计的话。
你就不用太担心雪裙的这个功能的确实。
所以我觉得可能衣服裤子从这个角度考虑。
然后当然你要说的品牌的话。
那肯定从高的说
就是我刚刚说的火柴裤。
它其实是一个定价相对比较高的一个价格带。
然后这个价格带可能还有十足鸟大象。
当然它们可能还是会有差异。
因为那个那几个品牌我买的不多。
所以我了解的没有那么多。
然后往下走的话
Burton你要说滑雪裤的话。
Burton可能是知名度比较高的。
然后纯从冲锋衣的话。
那肯定Noseface现在真的是非常大众的。
我真的来三里托周边。
我就看很多都穿那个Noseface那个壮色的那个冲锋衣。
然后你要说国产品牌。
那就是烫出者凯勒什还有骆驼最近建制。
太多了
薄熙盒就是今年因为他们这几年做推广的力度也很大。
然后我觉得可能还是从就是价位段。
如果大家要买冲锋衣的话肯定还是第一。
你喜欢什么样的价位段。
然后第二就是你看它的它的面料。
因为两层 两层半和三层。
这种Gotax防水的防水面料的这种。
就是它的这个防风防水的能力和耐用性是有很大的差异的。
就是虽然它长的一样。
所以这个就是肯定你要考虑。
就是你要想到一个就是我要买冲锋衣。
我花了这个钱
我就要买它的这个系数够高。
那你就一定要考量一下。
就是你不要光看这个链接。
它价格便宜
也是冲锋衣你就买了。
还是要看一眼它是几层的。
嗯
说到冲锋衣啊？
我也有很多话想跟大家讲。
就是因为我大概是04年就开始03年就入坑户外了。
但是我觉得每一个入坑户外的人。
会逼惊的一个过程是。
因为在这个行业里面。
大家都比参数
所以我们买第一件冲锋衣的时候总是想说。
哎呦 我要这个参数足够高。
而且大家陈敏于
不叫陈敏于
就大家迷路于这个在小红书上。
或者说社交媒体上。
大家对于各种冲锋衣的参数对比。
但我想跟大家说
就是首先技术这个东西也是够用就好。
我一定建议大家考虑一下。
说你买冲锋衣的使用场景是什么？
当然比如说有些人的使用场景。
其实是城市和偶尔的交由。
但是他希望通过这个冲锋衣。
能够建立一些品牌属性的标签。
或者说一些社交属性。
所以大家会去买十足鸟。
这个也是没问题的。
我觉得目标清晰就行。
那另外呢？
就是有很多人
其实他并没有这个诉求。
他只是希望说有一件冲锋衣。
也许去自己的城市周边。
去有一个单日往返的这样徒步。
其实你就完全没有必要去买那种。
防水系数非常高
参数很厉害的冲锋衣。
因为这里面有个点就是。
大家知道冲锋衣的防水。
比如说最有名的面料。
高tex都是通过这些。
科技面料上面的防水图层。
来实现它的这个功能的。
但是防水系数越高。
这个冲锋衣无论它的技术。
多优势说我有透气性。
它的透气性肯定还是不如。
真知产品的高
所以就是大家一定要根据。
自己使用的场景去判断说。
我要买一件什么样的冲锋衣。
这里面我给大家推荐。
高中第三个场合的选择。
就如果说你要去登雪山。
或者说你有一个比较。
超长距离的徒步
或者就是会去地形环境。
和天气环境都比较复杂的地方。
我觉得你可以一定要考虑。
冲锋衣它的科技含量。
一个是防水系数
一个是比如说你要是。
自己负重的话
是否还要考虑
比如说你要有换的这个衣服。
考虑它的重量
然后再其次才考虑它的美观。
然后以及它的价格等等。
但如果你只是一个。
相对比较入门级的朋友的话。
我觉得有一个中端的。
冲锋衣的很大的一片海洋。
可以供你去选择
这其中包括就刚刚Cherg说到的。
如果你想选择价格也是中档。
但是又有一定专业性的。
我觉得你可以避开。
那个特别火的那几个品牌。
国内有一些品牌的。
性价比是非常高的。
凯勒士这两年是价格。
是非常水长船高
但比如说像
探路者他有一个系列。
叫做HiMax
他这个系列的科技含量。
你可以去参考一下。
就会发现
同样科技含量的产品。
如果再加上它打折的时候。
它的价格甚至是
完全同等科技系数的。
国际大牌的三分之一。
甚至更低
你就可以超个底
然后这是中端价位。
专业度的
但如果说是
你希望中端价位审美的。
其实国内现在有
非常非常多的品牌。
其实它现在设计很好。
比如说有一些山西的品牌。
具体名字我不太记得了。
如果有觉得好的
这个大家也可以推荐。
它的那个风格会更好。
就是它的科技含量。
肯定没有我们刚说到的。
这个高端款那么好。
但是它在美观程度上。
的确是很有自己的风格。
然后还有一种
我前段时间接触了一个。
美国的高尔夫品牌。
叫猫本
那这个牌子也刚刚进入中国。
它非常的潮流
但是它的价格不低。
但是它也本身有一些冲锋衣。
这个冲锋衣我想肯定不适合。
我们说的极端天气环境和。
复杂地贸
但是你要如果为了美观。
然后只是偶尔
比如说我去北京地区。
有个单日徒步
我觉得这种是可以入的。
然后最后就是我们前面讲到。
切尔给提到说国产有一些。
现在卖的很火的那个冲锋衣。
三合一的冲锋衣可能只要。
三四百块钱
像骆驼 薄熙盒
我就如果你想
只是想刚刚入门
然后对其他没有太多追求的话。
我觉得这个也是可以的。
或者你买给家人
这也是一个很好的选择。
所以冲锋衣我大概就补充这些。
我刚刚提到说切尔哥推荐火柴棍。
火柴棍有一款
最近在国内非常火的。
我觉得也特别好看的一款衣服。
叫做黑武士
如果大家想是
我们刚刚讲到的这个高端品牌。
和高端专业度的话。
可以去研究一下这款黑武士。
我们在上期节目里面。
也有这个两位去北极的朋友提到。
因为它本身分不同的颜色。
就是有红款和黑款。
然后它的这个设计的场景也不一样。
有这个登山的和好像是滑雪的吧？
这个大家可以看看。
好 那我们讲完冲锋衣。
我们来到中间的保暖层吧？
保暖层
切尔哥你有一些什么推荐吗？
保暖层的话
我觉得先说品类吧？
我觉得可能就是压缩衣。
比如说因为滑雪确实是需要压缩衣的。
就是它的所谓压缩衣其实就是。
那这一块我没有特别深的研究。
纯技术啊？
我就是我这么样理解。
就是它会收紧性会很好。
因为在野外就是你保暖越好。
其实就是因为它更贴合你的身体。
所以压缩衣大多数。
它都是比较就是比较瘦的。
然后穿上去体感是有一点勒着你的那种。
然后就包裹性很好。
所以它保暖性就会好。
然后压缩衣其实有很多专业的品牌。
就尤其是在滑雪这个内幕里面也不便宜一套的上千。
我是之前就是机缘巧合。
我是买到了Las Potiva。
他们最早就是很少的一批在北京的样货。
所以呢我就买了几件。
就是我穿了很多年。
我也没买新的
然后这个
但是我觉得就是可能产品差不多。
就是因为你也不外穿。
就只要你穿着舒适。
它的面料它肯定是素干的。
然后稀罕排汗的功能会很强。
然后再有一个亲服感。
还有就是是不是更合身。
我觉得可能考虑的是这些点。
然后就是羊毛内衣。
羊毛内衣跟压缩内衣比的话。
它就是没有那么强的这种包裹性。
因为它羊毛它的弹力就是没有。
都不会很强
所以羊毛内衣它可能更多的是属于这种保暖的这种功能。
还有就是它的
就我刚刚说过了它的义军的这个功能。
还有素干排汗的这个功能。
当然羊毛内衣就是其实现在出的这种市面上的。
其实很多它亲服性已经非常好了。
就是它的柔软程度。
其实我觉得有时候要高于压缩内衣。
因为有的时候压缩内衣挺硬的。
就是尤其是在关节你拐弯的地方。
它还是有那种感觉的。
但是羊毛内衣我基本没有这种。
就是比如我弯割不走。
割不走内侧会有那种就是被衣服挤着的那种各着的感觉。
所以羊毛内衣现在可选的品牌就更多了。
老财可以补充一下。
我先把品类说完
然后中层可能就是再厚一点就是抓容。
抓容的话就是有保有厚。
也有那种摇里容就穿上去像小狗熊一样那种。
很可爱的
然后这个就会
我觉得可能就会更靠外层一些。
就是从内衣然后到中层。
中层的话我可能还会推荐的就是闭绵的绵服。
可能玩户外的人就比较关注这个品类。
就是因为羽绒服就是湿了之后会压缩。
然后它的保暖性就降低了。
所以闭绵相对比较安全。
就是它是属于有空气层。
因为它其实就相当于做了一些填充。
然后让你的衣物有一个空气层。
然后提升这个保暖性。
它是在有空气层的这种又防水。
又保暖的这种材料里面可能算便宜的。
因为现在有很多聚水羽绒的这种中层的羽绒服。
也是可以实现这一点的。
但是可能聚水羽绒整个这个品类会相对贵一些。
然后中层基本就是这些。
然后品牌老财可以补充一下。
我一个一个说
虚然说到羊毛
羊毛这两年风特别大。
如果大家对这个感兴趣可以往前翻。
我们有一期上过小宇宙首页的。
就是关于美丽奴羊毛到底是怎么回事的。
我这快速跟大家说一下。
翘罗刚提到羊毛的亲夫性。
其实这个还是取决于。
你的这个美丽奴羊毛的它的粗细程度。
纤维的粗细程度
基本上大家可以选择20以下的。
相对会比较柔软一些。
另外就是在价格段方面。
其实一些国际品牌。
比如说
帕特高尼亚的羊毛内衣的知名度就会很高。
所以大家如果不差钱的话。
可以直接入手这些知名品牌的。
然后另外就是国内有一些品牌。
比如说这两年
知名度也很高的
像奥特匹亚
我个人体感
他们家的衣服不算便宜。
但是是有保障的
而且审美还是很好的。
然后上一期的羊毛那期专题里面。
我给大家推荐过几个品牌。
有一个叫SN
SN
我要没记错的话
它被靠的是一个羊毛的原材料供应的一个。
我不知道是不是上市公司。
一个巨大的集团
所以他们家是有一定的材料优势的。
于是他们家这个全羊毛。
纯羊毛的产品会价格比较低。
但是我最近发现他们家偷偷涨价了。
这审美也变得好看一些了。
但的确在涨价
他们和奥特匹亚一样都走到了这个中短价位。
然后还有比如说这两年也营销做得很好的。
像Bee In Space。
也是一个国内的品牌。
我自己买过
我觉得很扎实
但是说实话
可能检财和审美方面。
你就不强求人家的有一个品牌叫暴走烤拉。
它的性价比很高
说到这儿
因为我们月下自己也在入坑和尝试羊毛这个品类。
我们今年是出了一短一长两个羊毛衫。
短的那款叫小羊衫短袖。
然后它的检财会比较的特别。
因为我有请的是香港的一个设计师。
但我们只有女款
它是15%的羊毛加85%的一个叫Naya的一个面料。
这个面料目前Petagonia也在用。
就是我们在尝试说。
有没有这个羊毛的穿着体感会让你觉得不错。
但同时起球会比较少一些。
在这有一个点
就是大家如果买到羊毛的任何的制品。
你发现起球
那个也不是商家的质量问题。
这个是一个世界难题。
目前还没有被完全的解决。
但如果你是羊毛魂仿的一些其他的产品。
那可能在起球的方面会好一些。
另外就是羊毛水洗之后。
大家都会发现它会变形。
都会变小
所以羊毛的水洗问题一直是一个难题。
但这个比起球会有一个比较好的科技进步。
就是如果大家在买的时候。
你标明这个产品可以水洗的话。
那就问题不大
我们自己的这款小羊衫虽然没标明水洗。
但是我们自己做的测试就是。
如果说你用那个洗衣机洗的话。
好像会有一点起球。
但还好
我们长袖的那款现在还没有上市。
估计是在10月中下旬会上市。
然后那个我们也是请了清华美院。
某一年这个工业设计系的第一名的毕业生。
来帮我们做的一款产品。
我们的定价会相对比较清明一些。
但同时我们加了一些设计的元素。
然后也看看市场的反馈。
大家感兴趣的话可以关注。
我们小羊衫的劝后价。
就是因为咱们的这个厅友。
都会有一个劝后价。
我们小羊衫的劝后价。
如果是咱们的厅友的话。
是369
如何拿到这个劝
大家可以在评论区随时问我。
然后那个长袖的定价。
我们现在还没出来。
但是相对来说
会比我前面提到的就是。
国内那几个品牌
可能稍微略低一些。
长袖那款是春阳毛。
百分之百美丽路上春阳毛。
而且用的是比较细的纤维。
所以新幅度会很好。
也欢迎大家关注
说完这个羊毛
然后说其实切勒刚提到了。
就是中间层的这个保暖。
提到有棉浮和羽绒浮。
这里面我也想跟大家说的一个点。
就是很多情况下
大家会觉得说
哎呀羽绒浮肯定更好。
但实际上在有些情况下。
棉浮会有它的优势。
譬如说如果你可能淋雨的话。
那对于
虽然现在有很多羽绒浮。
是巨水羽绒
但是在真的出现这个。
下雨的情况下
棉浮的保暖性
可能会稍微好一些。
比如说有一些使用过。
一些合成纤维
比如说有一些叫
什么Prima Loft这样的合成纤维的。
潮湿之后还能保持。
大概七八成的保暖性。
这个就会更适合于。
潮湿或者多雨血的环境。
但是如果你是日常使用的话。
我觉得羽绒浮相对来说。
会更轻
然后也会更舒服
再让我给大家推荐一个品牌。
在这没有太多的这个利益相关性。
它叫Mountain。
这两年很火
然后最近他们有一个动作是。
他请了朱一龙做代言人。
我们第一反应就是。
Mountain真有钱。
对 但是话说回来。
它是一个英国的品牌。
然后英国南北街探险队也会使用它。
然后它其实之前是以这个。
超轻的冲锋衣
作为它的一个优势卖点的。
但是我自己是因为。
前年跟它的中国区的CEO。
有过接触
然后他送了我一件。
是这个利益相关性。
仅仅而已
然后我穿了之后就被深深种草。
然后给我们家人美人买了一件。
它的那个超轻羽绒浮。
我买的那一款好像叫Antifris。
但它里面也会分出。
你不同的场合下用什么？
然后那一款大概价格在一千。
如果是打完折的话一千八九。
但是我是一个花钱还挺省的人。
但是真的真的很好用。
就是有男款的有女款的。
它最好用的是说在北京的冬天。
如果不是极端极端冷的那几天。
如果正常的情况下。
你这一件羽绒浮
再加一个内层的羊毛衣。
出行是完全没有问题的。
你身上就会很轻很轻很轻。
因为我先生常年是在。
南方在南方的国外工作。
所以他冬天就会面临一个问题就是。
他要带着很重的行李。
往返于热带和北京中间。
所以我给他买了这件羽绒浮之后。
他简直如握质宝
因为它叠起来非常非常轻。
可是它的保暖性又很强。
他下了飞机穿上它就ok了。
然后我在户外也试过。
我觉得这个品牌确实还可以。
除此之外我觉得大家如果对于羽绒浮这个内幕。
感兴趣再推荐一个相对评价版的替代。
它其实不是户外
就是如果说你是在亲户外的情况下。
或者是在日常城市穿着的话。
就可以去优异库看看。
优异库的产品确实新价比还挺高。
但是也有一定的这个专业度。
对 这是羽绒浮方面的推荐。
切尔哥对于衣服这块还有什么补充吗？
我觉得就是跟老差一聊。
你看你能看出来我这个长期主义做的其实挺好的。
就是当我在一个品类里有了产品之后。
我基本上就不太关注新的了。
当然我就是我可能会从新的技术的层面去。
或者说比如了解竞品的层面去大概了解一些。
但是我可能对这些品牌没有那么强烈的热情。
其实还有一个场景我们没聊。
但应该也聊差不多就是越野跑。
但是因为越野跑我们上上期的节目也讲过一些。
就在这一笔带过
就是因为还有素干衣和防晒衣这两个品类我们没聊。
但我的建议就是素干衣的技术现在已经非常成熟了。
所以大家就喜欢什么买什么？
然后我们之前在做调研的时候。
因为月下也出了一款素干衣。
不过说实话我们的素干衣更多的是。
它是仿绵制的一个Coolmax材质。
所以它的素干性一定不是最好的。
但是它就是因为我们用的是小IT的工厂。
所以它是有一个潮牌的属性。
就是如果你想要一个又素干。
比如说你出差的时候洗了四五个小时就能干。
然后明天借着穿的衣服。
我觉得你就直接入手我们月下的就行。
但如果你想要很专业的很舒服的。
Pathagonia有一款叫。
我想不起来名字了。
就是你搜Pathagonia的叫A什么还是什么？
它那款素干衣几乎是接服。
就我们街上去参加户外的活动。
就发现男生人手一件。
那个摸起来有一种黄油的质感。
那个是很好的
另外就是我们也在找那种。
因为我们我想突破的一个点。
就是素干衣很少有好看花纹的。
但Mumble的素干衣的花纹确实做得不错。
比较可爱
但是就是Mumble的那一款有花纹的。
跟我们的质感差不多。
就是都是偏绵制一点的。
所以它在上面的花纹实现度上就会好一些。
这是素干衣的建议。
除此之外各个品牌的都差不多。
你就搜比如说
Kumax这样的有科技面料的。
然后我觉得买买买就行。
然后就是防晒服
防晒服我想跟大家说的是。
衣服这个东西吧？
你只要穿了
其实它就有物理防晒的功能。
是吧 切尔哥
然后这两年大家对于防晒服的热捧。
其实是因为一个内幕的一个包装。
当然如果你要经常比如说在室外行走。
或者说有很多人要骑电瓶车之类的。
这种场景下
你需要大面积的去暴露自己的皮肤。
但你想防晒商的话。
可以穿一些这种已经很。
这个很成熟的防晒服。
在胶下胶内做火了之后。
现在各个品牌的防晒服类似的都有。
所以我这只是想建议大家就不用执着于这两个品牌。
各大品牌出的都有。
你就找自己好看的 喜欢的就行。
以及国内这两年有好多特别有设计感的防晒服。
也不贵
这个是给大家的一个推荐。
然后讲完衣服
我们来说说鞋子吧 切尔哥。
鞋子除了你刚刚说到的Last Potiva。
你还有什么其他的跑鞋。
或者说户外的鞋子的推荐吗？
特别少
因为我真的是Last Potiva的中粉。
对 中粉
就是我的越野跑鞋 徒步鞋 高山穴。
全都是Last Potiva。
但是确实我身边
就是因为我身边玩越野跑的人还是挺多的。
就是会了解到的一些品牌。
就是Salomon。
就确实Salomon的鞋也是比较好穿的。
早期的Tanica。
Tanica也是专门做越野跑的。
它就是有很多很厚底的鞋。
然后包括后来就是最近几年比较火的Hokka。
那Hokka其实我是之前曾经想要入坑。
我买了一双Hokka的鞋。
就是因为它的那个鞋。
一个是它设计其实挺时尚的。
它会有那种老爹鞋。
因为前一阵不是火了一段老爹鞋吗？
就Hokka的那款。
然后所以我当时就觉得想要尝试一下。
然后很多人也说它的那个鞋底很软。
就是有那种材实感。
然后我入手了一双。
但是它我当时入手的是一个高帮徒步鞋。
但是它可能刚刚好就是也有可能是个体的差异。
就是我就觉得我膜脚怀。
所以我当时就给退掉了。
没有深度的尝试
但是我身边有有那种跑步大牛穿Hokka。
就是它可能穿习惯了硬底鞋的时候。
他们可能会反而觉得Hokka的底片软。
然后支撑不足
当然我因为我没有亲自试过。
这个我就不太多评价了。
但我确实是我身边有很多这种拿成绩的。
越野跑的运动员他们在穿Hokka。
当然他们是有一些商业合作的行为在。
还有就是凯勒什
这个因为我都没亲自穿过。
所以我就我也不做评价。
但是确实是我身边穿的比较多的。
就是这几个品牌越野跑鞋。
对
但是其实我是觉得鞋这个东西就是它。
怎么说就是它需要的专业的沉淀数会非常强。
因为我之前就是因为我。
我是给Las Petiva也做过推广。
我深度的学习了他们的产品线。
和他们的这种就是演变过程。
工厂的这个这个体系化的这个过程。
所以我知道
第一它是意大利的品牌嘛？
所以就意大利做鞋本来。
它就是一个有非常悠久历史的一个一个城市。
所以他们做鞋就很严谨。
他们光鞋穴好像就非常非常大的库房。
是放他们不同的脚型的鞋穴的。
所以我觉得一个是看品牌的这种历史产店。
就是它的这个工厂是不是真的有这个实力去做。
因为现在太多数的很多这种新的这种品牌。
它也要做这个鞋
然后它的研发和生产的这个厂家。
可能并没有那么强的实力。
所以它只能买别人现成的鞋穴。
所以它的这个版型可能就会有相对的局限性。
然后包括它和各种这种技术的这种。
就是品牌之间技术签约什么的。
所以它也导致了
它真正能拿到手里的这种鞋的局限性是会非常大的。
所以我可能会更关注。
就是我认可了Speedway。
也是因为它本来它就是做鞋就是很系统体系化。
包括攀岩
因为为什么我认可它。
是因为攀岩鞋是全都是手工的。
然后他们攀岩鞋是有一个专门的生产线。
然后基本上都是只在他们那边生产。
就是国内
因为国内有他们的越野跑鞋和徒步鞋的工厂。
但是攀岩鞋是没有的。
所以就是我认可这个品牌做鞋。
因为衣服我说了不太合适。
但是鞋的话我确实是认可。
但是还有一个问题。
就是亚洲人脚型的问题。
就是鞋只有脚知道合不合适。
所以我一直强调的就是大家如果买徒步鞋和越野跑鞋。
包括攀岩鞋都是要去试的。
所以这也是就是很多。
比如说攀岩场地
他们会推很多各种不同品牌的鞋的试穿活动。
因为你不试的话
你是真不知道这鞋是不是合脚。
然后我喜欢老sptiva也是因为我的脚偏瘦。
然后老sptiva它就是更适合瘦脚的人。
当然现在可能是它更重是。
亚洲市场还是怎么样。
他们推了很多新的这种。
就是宽鞋圈的这种徒步鞋和越野跑鞋的选择。
所以我觉得就是鞋一定是要去试。
然后要合脚是最重要的。
说到这个
因为我自己穿的品牌也不算多。
所以我只是推荐一些我周围的人的一些评价。
如果大家对这个感兴趣。
我们之前Mia有一期讲装备的。
里面他讲过各品牌的鞋。
他的试穿
其中包括Hoka。
Hoka也是我身边的人。
就是口碑相对反馈最好的一个品牌。
然后说到萨洛蒙有一个点。
但是我在网上搜
大家会觉得说可能跟型号有关系。
就是关于防滑不行的问题。
很多人说穿了萨洛蒙。
因为户外的鞋我们要考虑说有碎石子鹿。
有上坡
它的防滑是很重要的。
但是萨洛蒙的防滑。
如果在小红状搜索。
大家会发现吐槽它的非常多。
我也不知道这个跟型号有没有关系。
其中也有帮他们去捍卫的人。
说他们的鞋是在越湿滑的地面上会越纸滑。
这个的确是有一些橡胶和它的结构。
是可以实现在户外鞋上面的。
的确是有这么一说。
但是我也不确定
因为有些人说穿着它的鞋。
在湿滑路面上就完全衰的不行。
所以这个就是大家各自来分辨。
然后刚刚切尔哥提到拉斯普雷巴的鞋。
我也试过
但我是一个亚洲宽脚扁平族。
所以以前反正至少之前的款型对我来说是很不友好的。
然后宽脚呢？
米亚推荐了一个品牌。
就是Outra是一个美国品牌。
它的脚型它认为会比较合适。
但是Anyway就是切尔哥说的鞋子。
合不合适合不合脚。
只有你自己知道
我们还是建议大家走到线下去。
是此外我给大家推荐几个路跑的鞋。
就我这么多年每年一双埃斯克斯的卡亚诺。
就是因为我是一个不求速度的跑者。
我每年的跑量也很低。
大概我一周能跑两次左右。
每次大概8公里也不求速度。
如果你跟我一样是这种想法。
然后又特别希望有材质感很舒服的话。
卡亚诺真的特别好。
但这里有一个购买的Tips。
你永远买比上一年老一版的那个版本。
价格就能便宜三四百。
对
其实也差异不会很大。
然后另外就是阿蒂达斯和耐克。
刚刚切了有一个理论我非常非常认可。
就是鞋这个东西非常吃沉淀。
这两个品牌这两年由于种种原因。
可能它的舌头就没有以前那么剩了。
但是它仍然是王
所以他们的鞋子本身我觉得是很不错的。
然后每年的双十一。
你可以去他们店里去抄底。
但我上一期节目也跟大家讲过。
就是要么去旗舰店看看款。
但其实很划算的是。
你也有时候可以去看看它的经销商的店铺。
因为品牌的旗舰店和经销商打价。
是经常出现的问题。
比如说你可以去淘博圣道。
但为什么我建议说。
可以去这种大的经销商店铺。
因为淘博也是上市公司。
所以它基本上假货的可能性几乎为零。
因为它出了这种情况对它来说。
这个补偿成本会非常的高。
所以我觉得大家可以去看看它的价格。
有没有能超到更多的底。
这是一个建议
我们讲到现在已经快过一个小时了。
才讲完鞋子
然后我们接下来讲讲包包好不好。
这是切尔哥很喜欢的领域。
先说切尔哥你有多少个户外包。
大的小的
数不过来
对
然后因为包也是一个重点品类。
就是人们常说的
现在最有名的三个三包品牌。
就是小英Grigory。
就是格里高利
和一个没有那么有名。
但是经常也会被放在一起的。
就是德国的多特
这几个包基本上会被提及的比较多。
你自己平常背的是什么包。
我现在自己背的是月下。
太感谢了
说到这
因为我们月下正确版还没有上市。
之前出的时候
我干了一件很蠢的事情。
说出来也给大家笑笑。
就是因为我们在出这本包的时候。
我那个化蛇天族非要在下面加一个adventure来表明。
它有一定的户外属性。
然后把adventure第四个字母。
E就写成了A
然后还是A写成
我到现在
E写成了A
对
然后这款包就是
我最后就是低于成本价。
就当福利卖给大家。
没想到三分钟就受庆了。
正确版的包会在11月晚一点出。
但是说实话我们月下的这款包。
它不是专业的户外包。
它是一个通勤包
所以我们先来说说专业的户外包。
你都背什么？
我可能更多的就是小英和格里高利。
这两个品牌会使用的最高。
大家从前面的这个内容也能感觉到。
就是其实当我拥有一款。
我觉得不错的产品。
在它还没有用坏之前。
我基本上不会买跟它同功能的。
其他产品了
所以这两款产品
也是因为我们早期在做这种。
就是户外营销公司的时候。
我接触到的品牌
而且是我认可的品牌。
所以我就一直留下使用到现在。
我有一个33升的格里高利的图布包。
然后它就比较轻
然后它是它背板偏长。
所以它的容量其实是比一般的。
单日图布包要大的。
其实一般单日图布25到30就够了。
我是属于那种喜欢带更多的东西在身上的人。
就是确实我不是那种急减主义者。
所以就是我觉得可能30升的包。
对于我来说单日出行是会更有安全感的。
然后它的主要是它的功能性会比较强。
就是它的收纳有非常多的这种挂点和这种收纳仓。
因为我觉得背包一方面是看它的背负。
然后再有一方面就是看它的这些就是收纳的这些功能。
然后单日图布其实一般不太考虑背负。
单日图布大多数都是背板是柔软的。
然后它可能会有一个胸带和一个腰带。
但是它的腰带不太具备支撑性。
它可能只是一个很薄很柔软的一个相对起到稳定性的这么一个功能。
然后就是我还有一款小英46升的重装图布包。
但是在重装图布包里面46升其实是属于偏低的一个容量。
所以在我比如说远图需要就是装东西多的时候。
46升对于我来说有点尴尬就是更短图的吧？
它有点大
但是更长图的呢？
它就有点装不下
所以后来我就把它就是出掉了。
然后我就又选了一个50多升的。
因为其实我是属于我更喜欢单日图布我不喜欢重装。
所以我这个50升的背包如果我重装我也能用。
就是比如说我背着帐篷和睡眠系统。
然后露营装备反而几几也能用。
然后因为再沉我是真背不动。
我就不喜欢背那么沉的东西。
所以我就选择了50多升的。
但是它现在更多的使用场景是比如说当我要去到一个图布的一个场景。
比如说我要去云南图布了。
那我可能带个行李箱不是那么方便。
因为可能中间的路程会比较电波比较波折。
或者比如我要去泰国的海岛。
然后这个去过海岛。
大家都知道就有很多我们去那种比较野的那种能方便攀岩的岛。
都是你中间如果你要拖着箱子的话。
它可能那个船给你扔的离海岸可能有个50米的距离。
你这一段要汤水
然后还要就是走沙滩。
所以就是一个大的背包是非常有需求的。
所以我可能就是把它替代旅行箱的这么一个功能去使用。
反而我的经验是40升以上的背包基本上都是有背负系统了。
所以在有背负系统的背包的时候你就要考虑它的尺寸。
就是它背板的尺寸是不是适用你的这个身高。
然后就是看它的背负系统的设计。
我觉得也是看背包好坏的一个重要的一个考量点。
还有就是背包的重量。
小英和格里高利就是我其实没有严谨的去做对比。
但是我身边是有那种比较较条的人。
他们会说格里高利的包普遍会比小英可能稍微重一点点。
但是这个我没有去考量过。
然后我最近也是就是了解到就是火柴棍的这个背包。
然后其实说实话我觉得就是重装徒步包。
其实同志化是很重的。
就是他们技术基本上都是类似的。
我觉得就是看你对哪个品牌更喜欢。
看看它的背板的高度是不是适合你。
然后看它的这个周纳的这些就是隔层啊这种小的这种小挂点啊？
你是不是喜欢用的是不是顺手。
因为重装徒步会有非常非常多的技术点。
就是它没有那么专业。
但是它其实是方便你使用。
方便你徒步的时候拿取物品。
所以这些细节可能是一定要认真去看到食物去体会的。
我喜欢装备的点
就是因为我可能更喜欢背包这个装备。
就是因为背包它可怕觉得这种小的细节会非常非常多。
我觉得非常有意思。
就像因为我这个理工女。
就是就像男生可能更喜欢比如动手动手。
然后当你拿到了一个大玩具的那种兴奋点是一样的。
就是我会认真的去研究它每一个设计。
到底很多时候就是这个。
尤其是背包啊就是你看不懂的东西。
往往就是它设计师的一个设计的巧思。
我就会有一种欲望。
就是我要研究明白这个设计是干嘛的。
所以我觉得这些点是就是刺激我更喜欢背包这个装备的一个原因。
所以如果让你推荐的话。
你就核心推荐的是这两个品牌是吧？
我觉得就是大牌包。
就是你说的那个另外那个牌其实logo是个地。
就是因为这个比如我在国外徒步的时候。
就是用这个包的人非常多。
就是可能还是就是他在国内可能还是没有那么大众。
然后但是他也是非常硬核的。
就我觉得可能背包的话。
我的理念就是我更喜欢买大牌的包。
因为可能我说的有点片面啊？
就是大部分国内现在会有很多这种户外品牌。
但是他们确实是在学习西方的这些背包的设计。
所以我觉得我肯定还是要买。
就是他们学谁我就买谁。
啊对我觉得这也是一个选择的很简变的一个原则。
就如果说你对某一个品类还不是特别熟悉的话。
如果在费用比较充足的情况下。
我觉得就入手这个比较有名的专门做某一项品类的这个产品。
我觉得就挺好
我可以补充一下
就是其实单日背包的话不用考虑那么多。
差不多看看重量还有它的这种就是。
它材质是不是够坚持它的做工工艺是不是够讲究。
然后你就看你是不是更喜欢它的外形就好了。
只是到了重装徒步。
带背负的时候可能更关注的是大牌的这个底韵。
因为它可能会确保它的这个功能性是更合理更全面。
提到这我补充一下。
因为切尔哥刚提到。
如果是重装徒步背包它的背板长度非常重要。
火柴棍最近出了一期视频。
如果大家感兴趣的话。
倒不是为了这个推广火柴棍。
而是那些视频里面它非常科学的告诉了你这个背板的长度。
和你个人身高之间的这个关系。
这个大家可以当做一个科普的点。
然后你量完之后再去选择你喜欢的背包。
我觉得也是蛮好的。
在火柴棍的小红书上就可以找到这条内容。
还有一个就是其实很多人买了就是专业背包。
但是根本不会用
这也是一点
就是其实我也是之前有过这样的体会。
就是在我看了火柴棍这一条内容之后。
我才发现还有一些细节是我没有体会到的。
比如它的肩部上面还有一个条节带。
它就是调整背包的重心的。
所以就是当你把背包全面的合理的调整之后。
它真的是可以分担非常多的重量了。
然后还有一点就是比如说在考虑入手背包的时候。
还可以逛逛咸鱼
对 这是一个很好的地方。
对 就是因为我买很好很贵的装备的时候。
我可能比如说我先是去品牌店去看。
大概了解一下我喜欢哪一个产品。
然后我都会去咸鱼上solo一下。
或者是海桃
当然海桃的话可能时间会久一些。
所以我更多会看咸鱼。
然后咸鱼的话
没准真的是能遇到有缘的商品。
关于背包我能补充的不多。
一个是刚提到的火柴棍。
它其实有一款叫limzit。
也是他们现在在全球主推的一个系列。
就稍微贵一点
但是我上次越也跑背着这个包。
然后因为它有两个软水瓶。
它的那个颜值是非常好看的。
然后这是一个补充。
第二个就是如果你入手一些相对比较评价。
但是也体验特别好的。
笛卡农的越也跑背包的口碑非常好。
所以大家可以去试试。
笛卡农背包
我忘了多少钱越也跑背包。
因为推荐给我的朋友也没有说型号。
但大家看看
因为笛卡农就是我们在准备这期的时候。
七二哥还说
如果一切都需要你有专业。
但是又性价比高的话。
你就推荐笛卡农
对
先去笛卡农看一看。
然后就是还有一个特别小的品类。
如果你要出国需要防盗。
因为我觉得这个东西在国内可能用不上。
就比如说你要装一些相机。
或者说最重要的你的卡包现金。
你要去到
譬如说意大利西班牙这些国家的话。
或者你要去中美洲的话。
一定带一个防盗的背包。
防盗背包
听闻的全球第一品牌。
是一个澳洲的品牌叫PACSAFE。
P-A-C-S-A-F-E。
PACSAFE在国内有售。
大家可以去买买这个包。
它不便宜
但是它能保证你至少防盗。
因为大家只要去过这些地方。
包括埃及
可能多多少少都有一些不愉快的经历。
对
然后另外就是
如果你特别喜欢很硬核的那种形象的话。
我觉得有一个品牌很适合。
它没有那么轻
但是真的这两年特别火。
我都知道了
就是神秘农场
对
神秘农场这两年火的真的是非常厉害。
但是因为它的确有底云。
它是一个美国品牌。
然后它来自于列装和军队的一些开发。
所以就是它的这个包。
就是如果你是一个很酷。
比如说你穿着那个什么Redwing。
或者说Tiberland的那种。
对
就是其实就是那种重装露营风的那种。
或者说就是军品军迷。
可能会更喜欢
你要说这个品牌
其实我也就是我之前也非常喜欢这个品牌的包。
但是确实我觉得它可能相对会贵一些。
就是性价比没有那么高。
所以我买了一个它的腰包。
这也是一个不错的选择。
对一个品牌的支持。
对
然后最后我跟大家说。
我特别爽的一件事。
就是自从做月下自己的品牌之后。
我发现如果你对哪一个品类有需求上的。
没有被满足
你可以自己做一个。
我跟大家说做月下这个包的我自己的逻辑。
首先它肯定不是一个专业火碳被包。
因为它只有17升。
但是别看它只有17升。
它有非常强的收纳功能。
就是因为我是一个。
我跟Tier哥不一样。
我极简
我去出差或者说我出去。
因为我往往出差要去到一些户外的地方。
可能要背一些你日常用的换洗的衣物。
洗素包
但是我出去还得背着电脑。
我印象最深刻有一年出差。
我是在玉龙雪山脚下。
看着我们的运动员在拍摄。
我还在那蹲在那用电脑办公。
就这是我的一个生存现状。
但是我个子又矮
我只有1米59
然后我不愿意说背着一个特别大的包。
压得我很重
我就发现有背负的包。
基本上都是要在刚提到的30升以上。
对我来说就有点太大了。
现在有一些包
我甚至见过28升做背负系统的。
但就很奇怪
因为背负的那个背架就会很重。
这样的话
而且还有一个
我也是
其实我跟老陈有同样的困惑。
也不叫困惑
就是使用场景
就是我需要背着电脑走任何场景。
所以其实带背负的包对电脑特别不友好。
因为它的背板是公行的。
它反攻的
它是为了让跟你的背保持一个定的空间。
然后就是它的收纳仓是有公行的。
然后它可能真正接触你背的时候。
还有一个另外一层里衬。
然后它让你的后背和你的背包之间。
会有空气的流通
但是因为它这个公行的收纳仓。
导致
因为你电脑其实就是要非常平整。
然后你一个大纸板放在一个弧形的面前面。
第一就是对电脑的保存是不安全的。
它会挤压
再有一个就是它其实会浪费一些空间。
它中间会有缝
所以我就会想办法用衣服啊什么去填补。
那这个时候其实就很不方便。
当你想要拿电脑的时候。
就会非常费劲
对
所以我的需求就是。
一它不是很大
所以我们开发了
其实这个包刚开出来的时候是28声的。
后来我就把它减减减减了。
好多次减到能够有足够收纳的情况下。
减到17声
就是说第一它比较轻便比较小。
所以轻便上我们也用的是。
类似于Lulu的包的那种面料。
它是有防泼水的性能。
因为防水的性能的话。
又会把成本和重量加上去。
所以它是防泼水的性能就足够了。
然后所以它轻便又小。
第二配色一定要好看。
就是我觉得25声以内的包。
基本上都是黑的
或者说是非常压抑的配色。
所以我们这次用的是一个三种颜色的配色。
它的主色是一个像那个木色。
就是因为我们这一期的主题叫山有墓西。
它是一个有墓墓的那种。
晚上的那种颜色
然后有一点点偏蓝和灰。
然后另外的是有一个春天的那种。
星崖的绿色
然后还搭配了一个草木茂盛的绿色。
然后中间又点缀了一个粉色的狐狸的刺绣。
就是整个
第二个就是审美我觉得特别重要。
第三个就是收纳
比如说我们这些牛马们出差的时候。
我觉得就像切尔哥刚说的。
那个电脑要好取用。
所以我专门做了电脑舱。
然后主舱里面有不同的袋子。
能够去匹配你不同的产品。
不同的物品的收纳和取用。
然后包括我们的拉链也做的防水拉链。
所以这个就完全是一个按照我自己的心意做出来的包。
但是就是截止目前。
如果要买专业包
比如说30多升以上的。
那我肯定还是会选这个其他的大品牌的包。
但如果你刚好跟我一样。
偶尔有单日图不需求。
你背的东西不多
要么就是你有两到三天。
或者三到四天以内的出差需求。
但你跟我一样可以用很少的衣服。
然后需要一个电脑。
需要一个洗漱包
这样的搭配的话
我觉得其实可以考虑一下月下的背包。
在这有一个不好意思的这个植入。
利益相关就是百分之百相关。
好
那我们讲完背包
因为时间已经过去了很久了。
我们最后再讲一讲那个三个系列。
第一个就是其他的配件。
其他的配件
比如说我们就着重讲讲帽子和袜子。
袜子呢？
就是我先说吧？
因为这个利益相关是因为月下又出了袜子。
我想说的是那个袜子。
其实是建议大家无论如何在户外的时候。
要多带几双袜子
而这个袜子的材质一定要好。
不一定要在月下的。
这里面我强推两种材质。
一种就是纯棉的
一种就是有羊毛含量的。
这两个我们都有
但为什么说要多带几双袜子呢？
如果在徒步的途中。
如果要我给你几个tips。
最重要最重要的一个就是。
你至少要保证一天。
比如说10公里左右的徒步。
你要换一到两次袜子。
当你保持袜子的干爽性的时候。
你的脚步的舒适度会非常非常的高。
尤其是你走比较远的时候。
获知这个信息是有一年。
我们去走那个玄藏之路的隔壁挑战赛。
大概是120公里的距离。
有分4天在沙漠里面完成。
我就发现我同队的一位前辈。
他的脚一点水泡都没有磨出来。
后来他就说
他每到一个大概4小时左右的时间。
他就出来换一双干爽的袜子。
这个事情太重要
太重要了
所以就是这个是一定推荐给大家。
但羊毛袜它的好处是。
一个是抗军没有什么异味。
一个是穿着的舒适度比较高。
我们月下今年初的。
去年初的这个羊毛袜。
叫冒胜的你
也是一款男生女生都能穿的袜子。
它的羊毛配比大概在30%多。
所以它不是一个100%的羊毛。
但我们加了锦轮和安伦来。
进行它的加固和舒适度。
所有穿过我们袜子的人。
就有两个反馈吧？
第一个就是会觉得它特别的漂亮。
因为大量的羊毛袜。
有些户外的羊毛袜。
可能会配色上会比较传统一些。
那第二个呢？
就是它很软糯
这个也是我们独家的一个配方吧？
然后这个是推荐给大家。
然后不管你买什么袜子。
都建议大家多买几双袜子。
然后另外一个就是帽子了。
帽子我们月下今年初的余夫帽。
但它就是一个比较可爱的帽子。
我初它的逻辑就是。
因为它可以折叠
我有大量好看的那种戴帽眼的帽子。
折完之后
出来之后就有一个很大的一个盒。
就不太好携带
然后月下的这个帽子呢？
它的特色是
一个是配色嘛？
也是山尤牧西主题的这个配色。
另外是
具体的大家可以看图啊？
我都会贴出来
然后另外一个
最大的一个特色是。
我们大量的余夫帽。
其实大家要去仔细观察。
它是圆顶的
圆顶的余夫帽
你可以想象一个日本的小女孩。
在临监徒步的时候。
幼儿园的小朋友
戴的那种就是圆顶的帽子。
但是圆顶的帽子跟时尚度之间。
可能会有一个矛盾。
大量的好看的
比如说那种绅士帽。
其实都是平顶的
所以我们这次是用。
余夫帽的材质
余夫帽的结构
但是做的是平顶的。
一个帽体
所以它会
尤其是我们黑色的那款。
搭配深色的风衣
在这个季节是非常非常合适。
然后白色的那款
特别知识分子风
我自己最喜欢的是绿色的。
因为它比较独特嘛？
是一顶绿帽子
配一个浅粉色的一个小糊粒。
然后后面呢？
我们还加了一个口袋仓。
这个口袋仓呢？
其实是一个
综合了它的设计的一个感觉。
它会比较英伦一些。
同时我们还有一个帽绳。
防风绳
它是可以取下来的。
如果你取下来怕它丢了的话。
可以放在那个帽子里面。
讲到这我都有点不好意思了。
就感觉这个广告的成分有点多。
但是我真的很喜欢这款帽子。
我们现在消除的情况也很好。
如果大家要买的话。
可以在淘宝搜索
月下商店
然后去给客服发
老茶两个字
就可以拿到优惠券。
或者在群里面
跟我们的小互利问。
然后除此之外
我来问了谦哥
帽子你还有什么？
除了月下还有什么推荐的。
我一般其实更多的是。
考虑功能性
所以帽子的话
要不然就是
比如棒球帽
棒球帽我之前
也是Adidas Stela的那款。
那个品牌
它出了一个就是
其实我更多还是看配色和材质。
它就是一个素杆的材质。
很基础的素杆的材质。
然后它是一个浅灰色。
然后上面是银光黄色的。
它的那个logo。
就设计很好看
但是它的一个小的亮点设计。
就是它在后面
它调节的那个地方。
它不是常规的那种。
N-Core的帽或者是。
有一个金属扣的那个帽。
它是一个绳子
就是户外的那种绳子。
也是银光黄色的
然后有一个小的素杆口。
就是其他设计很简单。
但是这种帽子很少有这样的一个收口。
就看上去很户外
所以这个是我比较喜欢的一个帽子。
然后还有就是
棒球帽是我比较喜欢的一个品类。
但是它的功能性没有那么强。
基本上就是看它的颜色和它的品牌了。
就是你喜欢什么品牌。
它其实就像一个logo带在你头上一样。
然后就是徒步的帽子。
徒步的帽子其实就是。
S-A就是
之前老陈也推荐过这个牌子。
然后我确实尝试了它不同的款。
然后它有一款是
就脑门中间有一个可以折的。
就是它的帽子比较硬。
那硬挺的话
如果你折叠这个帽子。
它毕竟它会有一个死的硬。
然后所以它这个帽子就专门设计了。
那是可以折叠的一个拼接。
然后那款帽子
还有一款是
就是它比较很柔软的一个软的。
一个标
它都是防晒的
它是
其实就是有点像
猎人用的那种
就是很常规的那种护外帽。
但是它后面就是
会有一个鱼尾的一个家常的设计。
所以它会对脖子会有一个保护。
这两款帽子
反正我都用过
它都是素干的材质。
有一款偏厚一点
偏厚一点
是我去年在4月份去云南徒步的时候。
就是高海拔徒步的时候。
我都带着它
比如说我在特别冷的时候。
我可能就在把我的那个外套。
就是羽绒服或者冲锋衣的。
帽子整个扣上
就是里面带着这个帽子。
我觉得就完全够
然后还有薄的那款。
就是纯夏季素干的。
它后面就是会有那种。
就是侧面会有那种透气网。
因为其实在夏天徒步的时候。
一个是你可能会出汗。
然后要考虑到透气。
还有一个其实头顶的防晒也很重要。
因为我真的是有一次。
我把头顶晒伤了
就是我的发负的地方。
就是晒得起了很厚的。
就像头皮械一样的东西。
那真的是被晒坏了。
所以后来我才意识到。
就是夏天徒步的话。
可能头顶有一层布的遮改也是。
也是有必要的
还有就是我把耳朵晒伤过。
所以就是其实徒步的时候。
有这种整个宽帽谣的这个保护的话。
真的是非常有必要。
因为我在户外徒步的时候。
你可能更多的是关注美景。
和你的路途的艰难。
你顾不上可能哪被晒到了。
然后包括我之前手臂。
就是小臂
因为我拿着登山杖。
然后我可能就是小臂这一段会露着。
然后我的小臂被晒到。
整个一层皮全都抛起来。
然后里面是一层汗。
特别夸张
就整个小臂的这个前段全都被晒伤了。
所以就是在防晒的时候。
就是防晒帽我觉得。
真的是非常有必要的一个选择。
切尔哥说到这个
又换起了我对SA的热爱。
SA是个什么品牌呢？
因为我们前面讲的长期主义。
就说建议大家一定要买。
它在这个品类里面。
生根有成电的品牌。
SA我要没记错的话。
它应该已经有三四十年的历史。
人家就只干一个事。
我就做帽子
它我是第一次知道是我滴妹。
她在新加坡生活
她给自己的孩子全买的SA的帽子。
后来我们跟这个品牌的中国区。
有了一些接触之后发现。
这个牌子的确是在美国和澳洲。
基本上是防晒帽里面的排名第一。
全名叫Someday Afternoons。
星期天的下午
名字也很奇怪
然后他们是做户外帽起家的。
所以户外帽卖得很好。
但是外打正招就是亲子帽。
现在成了他们家销量第一的品牌。
但我为什么特别爱它呢？
就是因为老柴
原本是一个不爱戴帽子的人。
就是我觉得头上有束缚。
简直是对我一个高智商人群的一个污辱。
就是我戴了帽子之后。
总有一种束缚感
感觉自己像戴上了金箍咒一样。
前面是开玩笑的
就是我自己的感受是。
帽子如果能戴到头上。
起到功能的同时轻弱无误。
简直就是太厉害了。
所以你就是前面
虽然讲到月下的帽子也做得很轻。
但是的确我第一款帽子。
让我戴上之后觉得。
哇就好像没有戴一样。
就是SA的一款跑步帽。
但是这款帽子
我是前年跟大家推荐的。
因为我认识他们中国去的人。
所以我当时只是发了一个微博。
然后有好多人说
哎能买到这个帽子有折扣吗？
我就跟他们谈了一个折扣。
这个里面也没有任何利益关系。
就是它卖出去多少。
跟我们也是没有关系的。
然后我就谈了这个折扣之后。
就把他们中国去给卖空了。
100多顶的库存全卖光了。
但这款好像最近又上了。
它就是一个很简单的。
旺球帽形状的
但它是跑步帽
就折起来其实也很小。
如果大家感兴趣
说到这儿
就是因为他们是外企嘛？
所以比较那个规则相对比较。
呃死板一些
如果大家有需求
然后你们可以在群里面喊我。
我可以把
我觉得特别好的这款。
然后发出来
如果能够咱们达到一定数量。
比如说他们能一次性发货。
我就去跟他们谈一个折扣。
因为他们不可能在公开市场。
去有一个折扣行为。
因为他们要
就是有价格的保护政策。
但如果咱们就是一次性的。
限量的
我去跟他们谈好不好。
这是那个SA的那个跑步帽。
另外就是
他们卖的最好的那款帽子。
就是切尔哥刚提到的。
其实有一款特别像贺本带的。
就是白色的帽子
女孩子带非常漂亮。
它是宽颜的
然后可折叠的
然后后面有一个
人家叫的很好听啊？
叫鱼尾的
但我们有时候叫屁脸。
就是大家可以理解它。
在后面是可以把你的那个脖子。
能保护起来的
所以很多人给孩子。
就是很多家长都给孩子买这个品牌。
但他不知道它叫什么？
因为这个品牌
居然连个中文名字都没有。
所以他就叫SA
或者叫Sound Afternoons。
如果大家有需求的话。
因为我们前一年做过一次团购。
所以才有的群嘛？
就咱们这个户外群。
才有三个了
其实都是来自于SA的这一次团购。
大家有需求呢？
我就再去谈好不好。
这是SA的帽子
我们配件就讲讲
袜子和帽子好了
我们接下来
最后两个部分
一个讲讲睡眠系统。
因为这也是我被问到最多的一个点。
其他的东西可能大家互相问问。
也就知道了
但是很多人这样年入坑徒步之后就说。
老差我想买个帐篷。
老差我想买个睡袋。
给我推荐一下
说到这个
切尔哥
你自己用什么睡眠系统。
然后给大家推荐推荐。
睡袋我用过的
四个盘子
一个是Nose Face的。
还有一个是Outdoor Card的。
Nose Face和Outdoor Card。
用的都是它们特别古早的产品。
然后贪录者的是用的是。
比较高端的一个系列的。
就是充装量非常高。
蓬松度很高
然后保暖性也非常好的一个产品。
然后就是C2SME的一个。
比较新款的一个产品。
我觉得睡袋可能对于我来说。
就是最重要的就是它的保暖性。
还有就是它的青莱化。
就是因为这个东西。
它也是一个矛盾的。
就是它越保暖
它往往就会越重
然后如果它又保暖。
又轻的话就对它的技术含量的。
考量会非常的强
所以C2SME的产品。
确实是我们最近会。
比较关注的一个品牌。
就是因为它的青莱化。
是做得非常好的
所以它虽然最轻
但是它的保暖系数最高。
说到这我也跟大家声明一下。
我们这里有利益相关性。
我们月下是这个团队是C2SME。
在中国的独家营销团队。
已经第三年了
所以这个还是跟大家说清楚。
但是我们的销售行为。
跟他们是没有关系的。
就是我给大家谈来的团购里面。
我们都是没有任何佣金的。
但是因为有了这种合作。
其实让我们有更多的机会。
深度的去跟这个品牌去了解。
然后因为我们也合作了。
非常多国内的大神。
比如说之前我们山海课堂。
请过的周鹏老师
然后我们还请过
比如说摇滚人 石鹿。
然后请过石头
其实这些人
尤其是石头和周鹏。
他本来就是C2SME的中毒用户。
我们当时接这个品牌的原因。
也是因为他在中国的。
专业人群当中的渗透率很高。
或者就是大家如果去看。
比如说班夫山地电影节。
或者说肯道尔的户外电影节。
就会发现在海外的那些大神们。
其实十个里面可能有六七个用的。
都是C2SME的产品。
这个也是奠定了他的。
在专业人群当中
睡眠系统的一个江湖地位。
但C2SME这个产品说起来。
如果说缺点肯定有一个。
就是贵
他除了贵之外就没有太大。
其他的缺点了
所以就是如果说
大家需要长期主义。
一步到位的产品的话。
我在这推荐的还是。
C2SME的产品。
但是他们的情况就是。
他们的产品型号非常的多。
然后又加上不同的参数。
Maya那个SK又看起来。
连我都看得非常的眼花缭乱。
所以在这重点给大家讲讲。
如果你要选账棚
一步到位
你要选一个什么账棚。
我在这就推荐
C2SME
其实它现在有一款。
特别有名的账棚叫Auto。
就A-L-T-O这个型号。
对 这个系列
然后Auto里面它有。
它是有单人账和双人账。
对 它单人账就是TR1。
然后双人账TR2。
对 就大家可以去关注一下这个。
我听了
这个不是品牌的人告诉我。
这个账棚背后还有一个故事。
就是它其实是有一个。
特别有名的设计师叫JK吧？
由他来设计的
你们知道就是账棚这个东西。
搞得跟奔驰一样
就奔驰的车型里面。
比如说AMG
它的发动机上是有签名的。
然后账棚
据说这个Auto账棚上也有签名。
这个我没有亲眼见过。
我看过他们家很多产品。
但我没有仔细留意过这个细节。
大家可以看一看
但这个产品基本上就是。
你可以理解成是账棚领域的AMG。
嘿嘿 我也是AMG车主。
哈哈 开心
你看就有品味的人开着AMG。
然后就是用着这个Auto的这个账棚。
对 然后你这个账棚的好处呢？
就是刚才C2SME说的。
它是一个三系掌
我们说的一步到位。
很多人问我的是说。
我能不能就买一个账棚。
然后我在大量的场合下可以用。
但是如果说你要去南北极。
要去爬出风
那可能它我觉得还是。
它有别的型号可以去支撑。
但是如果是Auto。
如果你只是这个日常。
比如说在华北 华中 华南地区 徒步。
然后偶尔去
或者是中高海吧 徒步。
就是4000左右的这种。
对 偶尔去个川西。
咱们就是这个场景的话。
我觉得这个账棚是非常非常好。
而且你拿出来
大家就会知道你很专业。
它的价格呢 大概在。
因为它有不同的内账 对吧？
它有那个布的内账。
有网面的内账
如果你要偏冷的话。
就买布的那一款
对
然后价格大概可能在。
三四千
原价三四千
不 原价应该是五六千。
对
因为这款账棚
我是 我有一个
是我是在咸鱼上逃的。
当时我在咸鱼上看。
大部分的标价都是在四千左右。
然后我找到了一个。
反正不到四千的
然后基本上没用过的。
就是其实真的很多人买了账棚。
就是冲动消费
然后它不用
然后就咸鱼上
当时咸鱼上出的其实也挺好的。
因为物尽其用
因为我不用的装备。
我基本上也都是
惯了咸鱼上就出手了。
然后所以我这款账棚。
我是去年为了去
香荣里拉那边图布。
我专门买的这个账棚。
然后这个账棚真的就是。
当我是了之后
因为我是一个装备的。
众多爱好者嘛？
所以之前就是对贪腐者也好。
然后所有的什么挪客。
什么这种就是
我能接触到账棚
我都会非常认真的研究它的结构。
它的细节设计
它的这种金属配件。
然后所以我再用了。
这个Auto的这个产品之后。
就会发现它的
很多就是细节的设计。
是非常非常非常打动我的。
更加热爱这个品牌了。
因为其实Citro Sammi的这个品牌。
它确实就是有点贵。
但是因为我最开始热爱这个品牌。
就是其实我也是一个。
Citro Sammi的一个深度粉。
就是因为它有很多小的装备。
因为我是一个装备爱好者嘛？
就它有很多小的装备。
比如说它的防水包。
它有很多小的什么量衣绳。
什么太多的小包
超新包
然后等等
就我可能拥有它
可能十几二十件产品。
都是早期就这么多年录出。
还有它的枕头
就是优行枕嘛？
就是我一点一点买的。
还包括雨伞
我都是用的他们家的。
就是因为当我认可一个品牌的。
这种某一个领域的设计。
理念和它的这个品质的时候。
我可能会就会去
没事就去逛它的这个店。
然后看它出了什么新的品类没有。
然后因为认可它的品牌。
所以它出的产品
我可能都愿意去尝试一下。
然后这些小的装备。
其实是很容易去做决策入手的。
因为它就没有那么贵嘛？
然后确实帐篷和睡袋。
是我最近两年才开始入手去了解的。
但是一旦我了解了之后。
我就确实发现就是它真的很好用。
就是它的帐篷真的有太多设计巧思。
去是我在其他任何一个品牌的帐篷里边。
完全没有见过的
嗯 举几个例子
我知道的一个就比如说。
它有一个帐篷里面的。
有一个那个包装袋的一个卷筒。
嗯 那个卷筒其实晚上你如果。
就是就像一个塑料桶一样。
对对对
就好多人不明白说。
哎 它不是超轻吗？
超轻怎么还这里放一个这个卷筒。
那个卷筒其实是晚上你在露营的时候。
你把它放到这个帐篷的。
挂到帐篷顶上
把你的头灯放进去。
它就变成了一个灯管。
它就会很亮
这个细节也是我们做山海课堂的时候。
由户外探险的主编。
他的主理人玄天老师告诉我们的。
他说哎 为什么我是Cedus Ami的中粉。
就是他总能给你一些这样的surprise。
对 真的就是在我用这顶帐篷的时候。
我也是就是他的这一个设计。
因为当时我就喜欢研究嘛？
因为当时我也是纳梦。
我说为什么它的帐篷桿的帐篷桿。
它有一个专门的口袋吗？
然后它帐篷桿外边还套了一个那个套子。
然后我说这个套子感觉很多余。
然后我就看了它的那个套子上。
会有一些简单的产品的那个。
演示的小图片
然后我就发现哦 它是。
因为它两边有两个小的按扣。
然后我就发现哦 我在帐篷内侧的顶部。
找到了先应的位置上的同样匹配的按扣。
然后我把它扣上
其实我当时没有特别认真的。
因为我学机械的嘛？
所以其实我对这个结构的了解。
我多数我不会先看说明书。
我先自己摸索
然后我给它按上了之后我就说。
这是干嘛的呢？
然后我就认真的看了眼说明书。
哦 它是让你把头灯放进去。
因为我们青莲化的这个录音。
其实很多时候我不会再带一个营地灯了。
只要有一个照明就够了。
那你把头灯
因为头灯是点光源。
所以当你把头灯扔到这个。
这个一个
它是一个柔光照的一个功能。
它是一个长型的柔光照。
它就变成了一个滚灯。
那这是其中一个点。
还有一些点就是
我喜欢研究装备就是我会。
感受它的质感
这个质感就是当你把这个装备拿在手里。
你才能够感受到的。
就比如说它的帐篷杆。
当你把帐篷杆撑开的时候。
就是它每一个连接的那种紧密感。
还有它帐篷杆整体的那种质感。
都会打动我
然后更直观的一些就是它的连接。
就比如说它的一些小的这种。
外帐和内帐支撑杆之间的小连接。
它是有颜色区分的。
这个也是会让就是对于。
就是第一次摸到这个装备的时候。
会更容易学会它怎么去搭建。
然后还有就是它的一个反支撑。
就是它很多帐篷它都是能理解。
就是它像一个乌龟壳一样。
它是都是那种拱形的。
然后给自己撑起来一个半圆。
或者说半球体
但是它在它的这个。
就是整个这个最高的这个顶的时候。
它的那个帐篷杆是反方向往天上翘的。
所以它能保证它的这个帐篷在你。
就是在帐篷内侧坐着的时候。
你的头顶是不压着的。
它是有一个横梁往天上翘的这种支撑。
所以它这个细节也是就是。
使用上特别的舒适。
包括它有很多细小的连接件。
这个我很难用语言去形容。
真的是在每一个就是在搭建过程中。
是一个很享受的过程。
太好了
所以如果讲到帐篷。
如果让我们推荐
我们就一步到位就建议大家买C2 Summit。
然后C2 Summit买哪款呢？
就买Auto
它有银色款有绿色款绿色特别出品。
但是常年断货
就是因为我在小公司上看到的博主。
基本都是绿色
我买的也是绿色
但我觉得银色也挺高级的。
就是Alto
然后如果我们建议还是买个双人帐。
对 会比较通用一点。
但是如果你就是个独行侠。
那你买那个TR1也可以。
就是AltoTR2。
这是我们对C2 Summit的账目的推荐。
它还有别的型号
比如什么Ecos。
什么还有一个叫Telus。
但是那些我们觉得如果一步到位就选这个。
然后那接下来
问的最多的来了
就是睡袋
睡袋就是大家都有困惑说我一步到位。
那我要绵睡袋还是羽绒睡袋。
我觉得从超清角度。
大家还是建议超清加保暖。
羽绒睡袋可能相对来说会比较合适。
但如果你要经常去一些会很潮湿的地方。
那就建议入手
又不怕重的话就入手绵睡袋。
但总体来说大家都会建议买羽绒睡袋。
那一步到位买什么呢？
我就建议C2 Summit最近有一款真的是火刀爆。
叫做Spark火花系列。
然后它好像内部有个名字叫小火神。
这一款就保暖性特别高。
但经常我会被问到的是。
它的问标也特别复杂。
有零下18
然后零下9
零下1
然后零上的
然后就大家就会很迷惑说。
而且就是每一个型号又有加长加宽版。
双人版
男版
女版
哇
我今天就是要整个要疯掉了。
但他们家睡袋的好处就真的是。
因为用的是聚水羽绒。
而且Spark这一版是850的那个蓬松度。
所以就是在保暖系数上非常非常强。
我就建议大家按照你的所在区域。
如果就买一款去去买它那个零下9的。
如果大家想知道为什么可以听我们之前。
大横断石头那一期的内容上。
它会有讲
因为它是一个一年365天里面。
可能有300天都在山里待着的人。
它就是Spark的忠实用户。
而且它选的是零下9这一款。
为什么零下9这一款比较适合呢？
就是如果你跟我一样。
是生活在华北地区或者华中华东。
就是主要你生活在中原。
然后你的场景是偶尔去。
你城市交区露营
偶尔最多比如我们刚说的。
就去一个川西四千左右。
但你又不是冬天去。
大概是三季就是秋夏春去的话。
零下9的好处是说。
你在夏天如果在中原露营的时候。
你热的时候
就拉开就好了
拉连拉开
如果你要是日常秋天。
可能就完全合适
零下9是它的这个温标是极限温度。
对它的舒适温度是零下2度。
就是你在最低温零下2度的情况下。
会比较舒适
然后如果你要特别冷的话。
就推荐你去购入他们家有一个东西。
叫升温睡胆
C230这个也把我弄得头晕眼花的。
就是他们家有无数睡胆。
有一些格脏的什么的。
但你一定要买去升温睡胆。
它的原价大概在也就几百块钱。
300到500之间。
然后叫Reactor那一款。
它是有那个红外的反射的原理的。
这个升温睡胆大概。
这个我不太严谨
就是大概你穿上它。
就睡觉的时候裹上它。
再睡到这个Spark的睡袋里面。
那个温度大概能升5到10度左右。
所以就如果你在很冷的情况下。
有这个升温睡胆就够了。
而睡袋是我特别推荐大家。
一定要入手的一款。
就是帐篷和睡垫你可以不买。
因为有可能如果你刚刚入门的话。
就先不要给自己添加那么多的装备。
比如说你去领队那边。
基本上也都有提供的。
但是睡袋这个东西。
就是如果睡别人的。
我总是觉得有点个影。
睡袋我觉得其实就跟内衣一样。
就是确实就是
因为我也是会接触很多。
这种户外的这种团体。
然后其实一般他们都会不建议。
就是说租用睡袋
迫不得已了
可能如果真的是你不方便携带。
然后有一些地方
就是可能使用场景又很特殊。
比如说只有一天两天去需要睡袋。
那你就必须带一个自己的睡袋。
但是当你有这种
就是长期去露营的习惯的话。
我觉得睡袋是必须的。
但是确实帐篷就还好。
帐篷你可以不一定是非要用自己的。
公共的也OK
而睡袋是第一
然后其次就是睡袋。
就是要有自己的
要不然就很不卫生就是这种。
对
所以如果说只选一个推荐。
那就推荐那个睡袋。
然后睡袋
然后就刚讲的睡垫。
因为C230其实这两年。
最有名的产品
除了那个帐篷睡袋之外。
就是他们家的睡垫。
对
就是充气睡垫
对充气睡垫
大家在选择C230的时候。
也很头疼说
他们家睡垫这么多。
我到底选哪个
如果只推荐一个的话。
那我们就推荐Etherlight那一款。
就是他们家的这个睡垫。
好在哪里呢？
就以前因为我年轻的时候出去玩。
基本上都用的是
淡潮那种睡垫
但那种睡垫的问题就是。
很大个
就是很占地
你只能把它捆在包外面。
对
然后这个充气睡垫的好处。
一个是轻
一个是我自己睡下来。
我真的觉得它的舒适度。
要比淡潮睡垫会更好一些。
因为它的那种
它叫什么结构
类似于疯锅的那个结构。
其实是
其实就跟那个
疾梦姿是一个感觉。
我跟你们说最好笑的是。
我们的那个合作的一个。
很专业很专业的博主。
就是野生埃马
他有一天
那个生病了在住院。
然后他就带了这一款睡垫去医院。
我说你为什么？
他说医院的那个床太难睡了。
然后他睡在这个睡垫上。
他的睡眠质量就会非常好。
所以就是建议大家。
可以入手一个
如果你要入手睡垫的话。
就用他这一款
而且就像
切尔哥前面说的
C2-3的真的很有将心。
他们这个睡垫上有很多的。
细节设计
比如说
之前我们有一个运动员。
我忘了是谁
他经常去高海拔
他说
哎呀？
这个睡垫是好
但是我每次吹气的时候。
都吹得我面红耳翅。
高原反应
然后我们都惊呆了说。
不用啊？
人家的这个睡垫设置了。
就是他那个睡垫的收纳带。
本身就是一个吹气的。
一个工具
一个吹气舱
就是你可以先把他那个。
就是就像咱们
就见过那种冲起沙发似的。
就是你先给他
迎风兜住
或者说你
他他一个是在高海拔。
这个就是防止这个。
就是你用嘴吹气很累的情况下。
是用那个舱收纳起。
就是你在空气里面兜一兜。
然后去挤到
因为他有一个专门的口。
正面是配睡垫
然后背面是一个更小的口。
是配枕头的
但是其实一般枕头。
两口就吹饱了
然后还有一个功能。
其实就是在你
用别人的睡袋的时候。
然后如果一直都是嘴对嘴。
吹这个气的话
其实很不会生
所以这个就是
你不用直接接触到这个。
吹气口
你就是往整个收纳袋里面吹呼气。
然后把收纳袋容纳一定的空气。
然后一挤压
把气再挤到这个睡垫里面就好了。
所以我觉得其实这个。
就是卫生也是一个。
特别重要的一个点。
然后还有就是说到他的这个舒适。
我觉得他就是因为。
就是因为我从很小的时候就录影。
然后那时候我去买的是。
迪卡农的那种超厚的冲气床垫。
但是那个床垫有一个问题。
就是你旁边要有一个就是很重的人的话。
就是那个你这边就会被压起来。
然后他就变成一个拱形的。
然后我就要不要往他那边翻。
要不然就我就往外翻。
就我经常就睡着睡着。
就翻到那个床垫和那个帐篷之间的分里了。
现在他这种就是像风波的。
就是他会有独立之声的这种感觉的结构。
你睡在上面就是你不会担心。
他的他有一边比如被你压扁了。
有一边他就高起来。
他完全是非常均匀的一个状态。
就是其实我小的时候睡什么气垫和什么水床。
都是这个问题
就是你就像真的是在海上飘一样。
一会往这边滚
一会往那边滚
那这个就完全不用担心。
不会说让你有这种就是。
就睡在一个真的是一个冲气。
冲气保身上的那种感觉。
对
然后说到这儿
我再推荐他们家一个神物给大家就是枕头。
其实他们也没想到。
我们也没有想到
C230在中国卖的最多的东西是枕头。
作为一个户外品牌。
因为大家可能之前在不同的地方看到过。
像刘亦飞啊？
包括好像李宪就是好多明星。
然后包括很多博主。
就是大家出门的时候。
都会在自己的背包上带一个小小的。
像口香糖大小的一个东西。
那个东西就是C230排名第一的优行诊。
这个诊头因为他有专利。
在全球范围内
基本上你要如果经常坐飞机。
你都会看到大家会拿。
就因为他的好处是。
他真的像口香糖大小。
但是你拿出来之后吹三口气。
他就变成了一个很舒适。
因为他那个接触面是一个偏容面的。
对对对 非常柔软。
很舒适的一个枕头。
然后你要放弃也就是按三下。
然后他就变了
你就又可以装回去。
所以这个东西的确是一个特别好的东西。
但是其实我额外要推荐的是。
他们家真正的枕头。
真正的枕头跟这个优行枕的原理是一样的。
只是说他那个
就很多人不重视枕头这个事情。
我前段时间就带着我小孩跟我先生去。
都不叫露营啊去长安公园野餐。
我们支了一个帐篷。
然后小小的那种小孩的帐篷。
然后我先生就想在里面躺一躺。
这时候就发现
磕睡了没枕头是一件特别痛苦的事情。
然后以及就是他们家枕头的舒适程度。
其实如果你对酒店的枕头有一些心怀借地的话。
我觉得你都可以买个。
因为他就充气的嘛？
就几口气就充起来了。
他也是那种就是
就像床垫一样
他是有支撑感的
就他不会说像
你睡在一个真的是吹气的枕头。
因为我我以前睡过。
没什么牌子的那种吹气枕。
就是他就是一个圆包。
就像比如说你拿一个防水袋。
把衣服装里一样
因为很多人就现在都有净锥病了。
然后所以就是很多人就很认枕头。
就是需要那个就是薄镜这块。
多少有一点支撑啊？
然后头后脑勺后面要有一点凹陷啊？
所以他的一个枕头就吹起来之后。
他就刚好是那样的一个形状。
就是而且他的亲腹感也很好。
他不像一般的冲击枕边上会有一圈那个。
硬的那个对就会可能会拿到。
就各的你的脖子或者是脸。
所以就是就这两点是我。
就非常喜欢他们家这个枕头的原因。
最后呢我们暂时没有谈来任何福利。
但是如果大家对他们家什么产品感兴趣。
就跟前面那个 Sunday Afternoon 一样。
就是大家在评论区或者群里面喊我。
如果能错过一定的量的话。
我去谈这个交给我了。
这是这么久以来为了感谢大家的支持。
我也不知道给大伙一些什么福利。
这个我去谈
好说到这我没想到这期录的这么长。
最后啊我们快问快答一些就是。
千歌你还有一些什么配件和电子产品。
能推荐给大家
先说配件吧？
比如说登山杖
就是其实我一直用的是。
炭热者的一个顶级的登山杖。
它是非常轻的一个折叠贼杖。
但是对于那个入门级的话。
我就是唯一的推荐就是迪卡农。
因为我确实对比了迪卡农的产品。
和炭热者这款顶级的产品。
迪卡农可能就一两百。
就是它的重量已经没有差多少了。
就是真的非常好用。
也是一个贼杖
我见过你炭热者那款。
它是碳纤维的
对对对
意大利生产的那款。
不知道现在停产了没有。
对迪卡农的确是一切。
如果大家要性价比的话。
就无脑冲迪卡农
一定没什么问题
对
然后还有一个
就是比如说说到斯特萨米的。
因为我刚才说了
我是从它的这个小件入门的。
就是它的防水包
超级无敌好用
而且它有不同的尺寸。
不同的颜色
而且防水包真的是体现了。
就是你在户外领域的遗物多用。
因为我们之前给斯特萨米。
还做过这种分享会。
我们有一个小话题。
就是让大家去分享。
你使用防水包
在一个什么样的不常规的场景。
这个防水包真的是太强了。
就是它可以装水
它还可以装你日常的这个防水的。
电子产品
药品
食品
衣物
因为比如说你在重装徒步。
或者说日常徒步的时候。
戴一套干净的衣服。
是非常重要的
如果你真的赶上去。
其实包前两天就是越野赛。
我们越夏群里面也有小伙伴分享。
它真的是只在一两分钟之内。
瞬间全身打湿
因为它又是遇到了。
本来天气很好
大太阳的天
然后遇到了冰雹
所以它瞬间就全身湿透了。
然后它当时就是
没有带一个防水包去装它的备用衣物。
所以它的备用衣物其实也是了。
然后导致它的转运。
因为它就被迫退赛了。
它转运
因为你在山上确实你很多。
就是你不可控的因素。
转运延迟了可能两三个小时。
它就会出现轻度的这种。
就是失分的症状
非常危险
因为它手脚已经开始发麻了。
所以就是防水包还有很多更多的这个。
功能可以去自己研究和开发。
但是我真的是觉得它太好用了。
因为它还特别轻
说到这个
这也是我这两年发现。
就是你去辨别这个人。
是不是大神的时候。
你就问他说
哎C2Sami你用的最多的东西是什么？
我以前以为大家就会说帐篷什么？
这些他们都用
但是他们说我们买的各数最多的。
就是防水袋
就每个大神
包括我们之前聊过的周鹏。
ROCKER 石头。
他们每个人都有10个以上的。
C2Sami的防水袋。
是因为如果你不长期在户外。
你不知道防水袋对你的重要性。
以及不同品牌防水袋之间的差异。
所以就这个的确是一个很好的东西。
好除了防水袋
就是你还用过他们家什么东西。
超轻小包
就是它超轻小包真的。
我觉得就是一个
一个手表表盘那么大。
的收纳
就是收下来就那么大的。
但是它非常轻
就几乎可以说是没有重量的一个。
一个小的耳朵
你就可以拿它当一个小挂件。
挂在你的书包上
然后它打开之后
它基本上是一个二三十盛的容量。
它打开之后你就更感觉。
它轻如无物的那种状态。
哦 我知道那一款。
但好像也不便宜
两三百
但真的太好用了
特别轻
我们之前拿那个当过礼物。
奖品送过
但是因为它的定价。
好多人一看说
哇 我两三百买一个这么轻的东西。
但其实C2Sami的哲学就是要轻。
我觉得它特别适合这人。
就是有收纳
又对高效非常有要求的人。
对
然后我看你
其实我上次见
C2Sami用过他们家一款。
特别神奇的东西
是一个防蚊罩
对
就是因为我经常徒步。
就是夏天
然后北京周边
然后我就
就徒步
有时候你进草叢
而且我
我还有一个第二职业。
是那个减飞机
就是我们要走那个野路。
野路的话
你就钻那个草叢
灌木
然后你就会根本就避免不了。
这个就是蚊虫定仰。
然后我实在是受不了了。
就是因为它就不管。
它就往你脸上飞
然后有腻虫也往你脸上飞。
就感受非常差
所以我就买了一个防蚊罩。
跟那个养风人的那个罩。
是一样的
然后比如说
我之前的理想
因为它确实如果你直接套在头上。
它就像那个面纱一样。
它会挨着你的那个面部。
会有一点不舒服
就像我小的时候出门带个杀鸡。
然后它经常会进我的嘴里。
然后嘴里那一圈就湿乎乎的。
所以我就会把它带在。
ICA的那个徒步帽子外面。
所以它那个徒步帽。
它是有一圈冒烟的。
它刚好能把你面前的这个空间。
给它撑起来
然后在外面再套一个罩。
就是确实是非常无敌的一个状态。
然后包括我夏天在北京跑步。
就是遇到那个飞叙。
哇 那个飞叙也是非常崩溃的一件事。
然后我就晚上跑步。
反正带一个那种就是空顶帽。
然后外面再照一个这个防蚊罩。
我觉得太无敌了
就这个这个配搭
我当时还发了一个。
朋友圈儿去分享这个这个配搭。
特别好用
就是很多人
因为弥術 轻度弥術。
那飞叙那么大的东西。
有时候进嘴里 进眼睛里 进鼻子里。
都非常不舒服
所以很多时候飞叙时期。
就很多人就他没有办法去跑步。
在户外跑步
那我觉得这个就是一个无敌的解决方案。
我觉得Citro Summit。
真的是一个特别好笑的品牌。
就是他们家有好多。
你根本出其不易的小产品。
就包括我们之前讲过。
他也出了想应Leaf No Trace。
就是大家要在野外环保的时候。
拉完遍遍一定要埋起来。
因为不然的话就会。
小铲子
对对对
所以那个我也埋了。
对对对 他会有一个小铲子。
然后包他们家的洗漱包很贵。
但是你用了一次之后。
你就发现 哇这是这人神器。
无论他的分仓还是说。
他的那个防水性
还有护照包
我也买了
哇塞
就是他护照包还有一个小的功能。
就是他防那个
叫什么 辐射
还是什么的
就是有的人
他是会通过这个什么东西去。
盗取你银行卡的那个词。
对对对
他是磁条的
然后所以他的那个就是一个。
就是防磁辐射的那么一个功能的。
一个护照包
然后也是分大小不一样的尺寸。
因为我特别喜欢在。
出远门去国外旅行的时候。
要有一个专门的护照包。
去装我所有的证件和卡片。
说到这我callback一下这个节目前头。
就是我其实私心最想给大家。
推荐他们家的一个东西。
就是毛巾
因为我当时看到那份调研报告之后。
我真的心里都凉了。
就是这么多人使用一次性毛巾。
就其实我也没想到。
就是大家真的不差钱嘛？
就是先不说环保不环保。
就一次性毛巾你天天买天天买。
但我完全也理解说。
大家因为觉得一次性毛巾更加的方便。
你买完就扔了就完了。
但其实我是觉得
真的是可能舆论的引导。
就是因为在我刚开始关注重装途布。
这个领域的时候
我也是会到网上去搜索。
然后就是真的搜索结果。
他就是给你推一次性毛巾。
我确实都因为这个买过。
因为他也很非常非常便宜。
所以他角色成本很低。
他推了之后我就买了事。
然后就是我买了之后。
我发现这个完全就不符合。
我去户外的旅行的这样的一个就是习惯。
就是我因为我喜欢就是物尽其用。
我喜欢这个毛巾就我泡开了之后。
我舍不得扔
所以就会出现更多的困扰。
就是我还得收着它。
然后然后它又没有那么好用。
所以就是我就觉得这个当时真的。
我就是被就是这个平台推的这个东西。
去困扰到我了
又接触了
因为那个时候其实我最早。
就是这个用我的之后发现。
这不是我的一个使用习惯。
然后我就开始去找。
就是苏干毛巾
然后因为他他也是会推到。
我最早买的其实是迪卡农的苏干毛巾。
嗯
然后我就发现这个品类其实才是。
我觉得对于户外爱好者就是。
嗯
徒步爱好者就是最终的归属。
对
所以也推荐大家
因为买一丝毛巾
大家无非是因为他。
呃
就是轻
然后方便嘛？
但其实如果大家看一下。
就是STS的
就C2 Summit的这个苏干毛巾。
它非常非常的小
它叠起来也就是
因为它有那个
你希望那个质感好一点。
它会有稍微大一点的。
然后你要希望薄薄的。
至少它质感不比一次性毛巾差。
它可能只有一半巴掌。
大左右
因为我们都买的
它甚至还有预金
所以就如果你对这个有需求。
我是建议
大家一定买这种毛巾。
然后它也很
苏干毛巾也很快干。
就如果你用完之后。
你就搭在你的背包外面。
你走个早上
可能走个两个多小时。
它就干了
所以这样的话
能帮你省很多的成本。
这个也更符合长期主义的。
这个原则
而且更环保
对
这是推荐给大家的核心的一个。
然后另外就前面讲的水袋包。
我忘了另外一个
特别重要的品牌
就是Kamalback。
Kamalback因为我们也有合作。
就是它是Utmb。
这么多年来的
独家水剧的供应商。
是因为它本来就是水袋包起家的。
它大概80年代
还是90年代
它的创始人是一个。
美国的医生
他在自己骑行的时候。
就发现喝水特别不方便。
就发明了水袋包
所以他们家的水袋包。
跟赛土三平的一样。
就除了贵
也都没有毛病
但是如果
我之所以提到这个。
我就在想说
我给大家能要哪些福利呢？
我想想
就是这里面我能去谈的。
不一定人家答应
就是这个Kamalback的水袋包杯子。
包括他们的杯子特别好看。
就是之前欧阳娜娜。
然后阿兴
都用他们家的杯子。
阿兴用的是那一款。
就是办公的时候可以用的。
那个叫Tumbler的那个杯子。
欧阳娜娜用的是
他们家的儿童水杯。
但就很可爱
就这些我都可以去谈。
还有就是我们讲到。
其他配件像那个鲁头。
如果你真的是重装徒步。
需要在野外有做饭的需求的话。
就国内现在
或者大神们通用的。
就会讲的一个品牌。
就是杰保
就是Jetboyle。
J-E-T-B-O-I-L。
Jetboyle的鲁头。
他也许我也可以谈。
但是就一定要有一定的量。
我可以去试试
还有啥
配件讲了这么多
主要是我一直看了这时间。
我的内存卡快不够了。
还有一个小tips。
就是在你徒步露营的时候。
我非常非常推荐的一个产品。
就是洗脚盆
我的天呐
那你这真的跟清亮话没关系。
我录音
我跟你说
鲁头三面的有一个超轻的洗脚盆。
他家还有洗脚盆呢？
我都知道我都被不尝试。
其实他不是洗脚盆。
他是一个水盆
就是他有不同尺寸的水盆。
然后但是因为我特别容易高反。
所以我在高海拔徒步。
晚上我必须要跑脚。
否则我晚上脚根本暖不过来。
就睡不着觉
我必须要用一个这种。
就是能折叠的便携水盆。
我在最开始徒步
去行走的力量徒步供赶的时候。
我就带了一个
不是清亮话的水盆。
因为那次我们有驼队。
然后他就不是很方便。
然后结果后来我发现。
鲁头三面的有
我就买了
他是不一样生殊的水盆。
但是我刚好买了一个尺寸。
就是他能泡脚
当然你可以拿他洗菜。
这么说有点不文明。
但是他也是一物多用的。
他就可以当一个水盆。
你拿他装水
就是容纳水
然后能干一切
就是需要放水的东西。
对于我来说
就是脚盆可能更重要。
就是我必须要泡脚。
在就是高海拔的地区过夜的话。
但这个太好了
因为我也会手脚冰凉。
然后在高海拔如果能够泡脚。
天哪
因为你看咱们前两天聊过。
就是那个哈格拉夫斯他们做的。
那个skit camp。
就是他们就在聊
就是晚上
因为北欧真的非常冷。
然后你在北欧人
他们就会有一个传统。
就是做桑拿嘛？
那桑拿是什么？
你是需要有一个就是场景。
或者说就一个设备。
有一个桑拿间
或者说桑拿帐篷
你需要有这样的补给。
你才能实现
那你说我们在国内的这种高海拔徒步。
唯一能做的就是烤火。
对吧？
但是烤火它是就是很热烈的。
就是你正面就烤糊了。
背面还冷着呢？
所以烤火对于我来说不足够。
所以我就必须在
每天晚上睡觉之前。
会在帐篷里面
当然前提是你们取水方便。
你能烧足够的热水的情况下。
我就会泡个脚
我已经被种草了
因为我们10月份。
10月底要去穿溪。
我觉得如果你走了一天路之后。
能这么泡泡脚
特别爽
哦
就真的就很住眠
因为其实我在露营。
露营就是最重要的。
就是尤其是在高海拔。
偏冷的地区露营
最重要的就是你在睡前。
要把自己身体搞暖。
你才能睡着
同学们
咱们团购这洗脚团吧？
大概多少钱
确实也不太便宜
但是就是可能两三百。
我已经不太记得了。
但是我觉得
因为它对于我来说很重要。
所以我觉得
我可以接受
我这个确实没有去嫌疑。
我是买的正品
这要洗
是正价的
我看了一下
对 确实
不能说洗脚盆
就是他们家水盆是有超轻和普通的。
两种规格
然后我买的超轻的。
因为我觉得我可能。
还是会有这种重装徒步的可能的。
但是我搜出来
都没有看到他们家旗舰店有。
现在旗舰店是一百七。
那还行
同学们
你要看眼生鼠
要不要我们去
我看了这个是时生不可直立。
还有二时生可直立的。
对
我就不可直立的就好了。
因为你装上水
就是能装水就行
其实就很浅的热水。
就能把脚面磨过去就OK。
还有加后款一百七十八。
那种就会重一些
因为这个我特意研究了它的数据。
如果要的人多
我就去问问他们有没有库存。
然后跟他们CEO聊一聊。
目前为止
我种草了好多东西。
但最种草的居然是个盆。
就是主要是这个经验。
我真的觉得是很有必要分享给大家的。
好的
太好了
最后我们再讲讲电子产品。
电子产品你有什么推荐吗？
昨晚我们俩做准备工作的时候。
我还说相机咱俩实在是没什么好分享的。
因为我们俩是一样的。
一人买了一个富士。
但是型号不一样
是因为
但这简简单单推荐一下富士。
是因为它那个有绿镜。
对
然后我买的是最轻的那一款。
就是XS20
我的需求就是轻
然后配的是它套机的镜头。
所以就会塑料镜头。
但是就是轻
这是一个
对
这个不叫推荐
如果有更专家的朋友可以告诉我们。
手表的话
因为我一直是加名的老粉。
但是最近我用高池就发现。
如果你的续航要求特别高的话。
哎呀？
这个续航太爽了
然后飞的那个飞机。
咱俩推荐一个
哦
哈佛
对对对
一个国产的品牌
也是我们我也认识他们的那个CEO。
我也不知道能不能团购。
就是它不是大疆那种厉害的那种飞机。
但是它好智能
也就是好傻瓜
就是我觉得就是现在。
因为大家都有这种一个人去互爱。
然后又希望能出片的困扰。
就包括我在那都是有的。
就是比如说
我就喜欢一个人出去。
我觉得没有约束
然后但是我就很难拍到。
好看的大片
因为就是这个机位的这个局限。
然后哈佛他有很多这种跟拍的模式。
我觉得特别牛
就是他可以才正面跟拍。
比如说你你倒着走。
转圈什么的
他他就跟着你走
然后还有一个就是他在你背面跟拍。
就是越野跑的时候。
比如说就是越野跑场景。
我觉得是真的
越野跑和图部是最适合的。
比如说你在一个特别开阔的山脊。
然后两侧有非常壮丽的风景。
然后你手持设备
或者说定一个定点的一个设备。
是没有办法拍到那个动态感觉的。
你就可以设置一个跟拍模式。
你就跑
他就一直跟着
然后他就
而且他不需要你任何的操控。
就是在你跑的这一短短的时间之内。
他不需要操控
所以我觉得就是
可能出几秒的这种素材。
完全足够了
然后再有一个
就是他使用可能比较傻瓜。
就是因为我们就是。
你要学无人机飞行。
可能会
你还要用手机或者说。
用他的一个手柄去操控他。
这个完全不用
就先在手机APP上设置一个模式。
然后他就可以飞了。
我的这个台是上次跟上次去参加。
火灯CEO送的
然后真的
尤其是因为我可能比较笨。
所以大家我暂时学不会。
然后但是这个哈佛就是一件事操作。
他有那种就像
切尔哥说的跟随功能。
上次我们在虫里越野跑的时候。
看到有人在用
对
然后比如说
因为有一些地方有进飞。
但是比如说我去国外旅行的时候。
我带着小孩
哇 这是简直红小孩神器。
飞起来之后身边所有的小孩。
都会对你的小孩头去羡慕的眼光。
然后对 确实是比较。
我看一下他的价格。
他现在促销
可能最便宜的款道也不便宜。
就是券后是2299。
那我估计双十一会更便宜一些。
他有几个使用场景。
我觉得刚好我们就是这个UTV的这个团队。
也是被这个哈佛赞助了。
然后但是赞助只是给了我们几台样机。
让我们去测试
因为他们也是在摸索这个产品。
在户外的场景下的使用体验。
但是确实我们测试了之后。
发现就是他跟随UTV是有障碍的。
因为他其实是对人体的锁定会比较强。
当人坐进车里的时候。
他可能就跟不上了。
所以我们在开UTV的时候。
可能我们只有在山顶。
就是风景最好停下来拍摄的时候。
会守控他去做一些。
真正的无人机的拍摄的这种视角。
然后还有一个就是滑雪的场景。
滑雪可能速度有点快。
是不太适合的
因为他虽然能跟着人。
但是当你速度起来的时候。
他飞不了那么快
因为这个东西他非常的小巧。
他就手比手掌稍微大一点点。
他真的他我觉得
可能就是重装徒步是适合的。
当你真的就是非常需要可能几秒。
一个很短的这个素材。
航拍素材的时候
他绝对是一个就是不可替代的产品。
然后他的但是他的bug。
一个是速度跟不了太快。
一个是他跟不了
就是你人进了车里他跟不上。
还有一个就是他的这个续航。
可能会相对短
因为他确实真的非常轻巧。
所以他那个大风的时候也不太行。
因为风一出
对对对
因为他的那个动力没有那么强。
他特别轻
他就是你手掌拿着就感觉跟没有一样。
特别小
对对对
所以这个就是可能还是根据。
大家的使用场景去做这个推荐。
但是他就是一个很神奇的发明。
是的是的是的
就很适合出街选手。
对对对真的就是单人。
因为我单人
我身边有很多这种户外的就是KOL。
他们就喜欢一个人出去。
然后就是简单的拍一拍自己的素材。
然后需要不同的机位。
这个时候我觉得就非常非常推荐哈佛。
嗯
好的好的
我们这一期聊这么多。
我觉得肯定还
就咱俩知道的肯定也都没聊全。
但是我觉得就是给大家一些启发。
更重要的是
欢迎大家在评论区推荐你用过的好物。
这样群众的力量才是最大的。
然后我们会把这一期的节目链。
接引发在咱们的群里面。
这样在群里面大家也可以讨论。
然后以及如果我能带来一些福利的话。
就是大家听到其中哪些品牌。
包括包括我们提到什么神秘农场啊什么的。
我也都是认识他们的人道。
但是我不确定能不能谈来团购啊？
就是你们对什么品牌感兴趣。
先说我去问问
比如说刚刚就在节目录制期期间。
也有人问我说那个snowpeak能不能谈到团购。
哎我恰巧也认识
当然我问了一下他们团购的旗并额实在太高了。
也许我觉得我们凑不够。
所以就是你们但凡想到什么？
因为在坏行业这么多年嘛？
就如果感兴趣可以说。
然后我们今天着重推荐的这几个品牌。
我提到的说我一定能去谈到的。
我应该都可以去试试。
月下的咱们自个儿的品牌的群友。
就一直都会有折扣。
在群里面会发也会。
嗯就是大家可以直接去月下上店。
然后给客服发老财。
就会拿到大额的这个优惠券。
其他的呢？
今天就暂时这样装备我们长聊长心。
然后也欢迎大家给我们提供更多的选题。
如果你有想要录制播客的一些想法。
也欢迎来找我们
但是辛苦切尔哥
切尔哥我们自己人我就不说感谢了。
哈哈
然后如果大家对于切尔哥有一些具体的。
呃问题的话
比如说第一期我们就讲到他。
关于他做摇滚歌手。
摇滚鼓手和这个减飞机的故事。
你们也可以回头去。
看看他的故事
或者说对他现在的。
工作和他之前的路线呀？
装备上有些疑问的。
欢迎大家在群里面找到切尔哥。
或者在小红书
你的小红书叫
宝超仓库马千
对大家就可以搜到。
好
那我们这期节目就到这里了。
这个也许是我们史上最长的一期节目。
欢迎大家接着关注。
谢谢大家
拜拜
想要了解更多节目信息。
或许文字节影像资料。
欢迎关注公众号月下。
三山五月的月
上下的下
小红书也有我们的同名官方账号。
如果你也想和更多爱好者交流。
欢迎加入我们的社群。
进群方式添加小助理的微信。
月下Fox
Y-U-E-X-I-A-F-O-X。
拉尼入群
最后也欢迎你在全网关注。
我们的女性户外品牌月下。
咨询小助理可以直接获得。
播客听友专属优惠券。
让我们月下相逢
欢迎加入我们的社群。
进群方式添加小助理的微信。
月下Fox
Y-U-E-X-I-A-F-O-X。
拉尼入群方式添加小助理的微信。
月下Fox
Y-U-E-X-I-A-F-O-X。
拉尼入群方式添加小助理的微信。
月下Fox